Alright, so we're having a cold open contest right here. We're trying to create the world's worst cold open. Well, not yet. I'm just teeing it up. Will would you like to start the world's worst cold open? Hey man, it's freezing in here the world's worst cold open? Hey man, it's freezing in here. Who left the door open?
好的，我们现在要进行一场冷开场比赛。我们正试图创作世界上最糟糕的冷开场。好吧，还没开始。我只是在做铺垫。威尔，你想开始世界上最糟糕的冷开场吗？嘿伙计，这儿冷死了，谁把门打开了？
Pretty good. Welcome to SmartList. It feels like we haven't done this for quite a while. I know. I miss you guys. We canceled a record last week, I think. Yes, we had. So it's been a couple weeks. Is that right? Yeah.
相当不错。欢迎来到SmartList。感觉我们已经很久没录这个节目了。我知道。我很想你们。我想我们上周取消了一次录制。是的，确实取消了。所以已经过去几周了。是这样吗？是的。
It's been a few weeks. Well, we saw each other Saturday. We did. We did. But we haven't done this. This. We haven't done this in quite a while. We haven't. Jay, how saw each other Saturday. We did. We did, but we haven't done this. We haven't done this in quite a while. We haven't. Jay, how's your stye, by the way?
已经过去几周了。好吧，我们周六见过面。我们确实见过。但我们还没做过这个。这个。我们已经很久没做这个了。确实没有。杰伊，顺便问一下，你的麦粒肿怎么样了？
Jason's got a big stye in his right eye. It's disgusting. Are we going wide on this? I guess. I can lean in. Yes, we are. The camera here. There's a little.
杰森的右眼长了一个大麦粒肿。真恶心。我们要拍特写吗？我想是的。我可以凑近点。是的，我们要拍。摄像机在这儿。这儿有个小东西。
You know what, it actually looks, is it better? It does look better. I started an antibiotic last night, so that's supposed to cure it. Already? Yeah, I know. You wanted to wait two weeks just to make sure. It's all about trying to find the right doctor.
你知道吗，其实看起来，是不是好点了？看起来确实好点了。我昨晚开始用抗生素了，应该能治好它。这么快？是啊，我知道。你本来想等两周以确保万无一失。关键在于找到合适的医生。
So anyway, so I think I'm with the right one now, and what is now a ball bearing of pus that will not release from my eyelid, I think is gonna start to lessen and ultimately disappear. I would love that. So you found a full release doctor? I did.
总之，我想我现在找对人了，那个原本像脓包一样、在眼睑上怎么也消不掉的东西，我想应该会开始变小，最终消失。我太希望这样了。所以你找到了一个能彻底解决问题的医生？是的。
Yeah. And insurance covered it all. That's so stupid. It was a small copay, but. I feel like the term doctor might be pretty loosely applied. Jay, I'm not even, Jason, I'm not even kidding. Will you please, will you please video this shit coming out? There is not gonna be, I asked him to drain me yesterday.
是的。而且保险全包了。太蠢了。虽然有个小额自付额，但是。我觉得“医生”这个词用得有点太随意了。杰伊，我不是，杰森，我没开玩笑。你能，你能把这玩意儿挤出来的过程拍下来吗？不会有的，我昨天让他帮我排脓。
Hang on, hang on, again, this is the doctor. Can I get the number? Because I feel like we're getting our signals across. He said no, just take this pill and you should be okay and soon. So, stand by. Good, I hope so. Until then I'm gonna wear these glasses so people don't really see it.
等等，等等，再说一次，这是医生。能给我那个号码吗？因为我觉得我们沟通有误。他说不，只要吃这颗药，你应该就没事了，很快就会好。所以，等着瞧吧。好，我希望如此。在那之前，我会戴上这些眼镜，这样别人就看不出来了。
Which is different, because Sean, you told me once that a guy gave you a pill and then he drained you, is that true? All for pretty affordable copay. You woke up and you had been drained. Yeah, but I willingly took the pill. By the way, speaking of stuff, I'm making this up, yesterday,
这不一样，因为肖恩，你曾经告诉我，有个人给了你一颗药，然后他就把你“排空”了，这是真的吗？而且自付额还挺便宜的。你醒来时就已经被排空了。是啊，但我自愿吃了那颗药。顺便说一下，说到这些事，我这是编的，昨天，
I was talking about this subject, oh, I was talking about this Saturday too. I YouTubed childbirth. I've never seen a child being birthed. I was talking about this Saturday too. I YouTube'd childbirth. I've never seen a child being birthed. What's the matter with you? I don't know, I kind of wanted to just see it. Hang on, how does your day kind of like,
我正在谈论这个话题，哦，我周六也在谈论这个。我在YouTube上搜了分娩过程。我从来没见过孩子出生。我周六也在谈论这个。我在YouTube上搜了分娩过程。我从来没见过孩子出生。你到底怎么了？我不知道，我就是想看看。等等，你的一天是怎么安排的，以至于你会去YouTube搜索，而且还是专门搜分娩？因为我当时在和我的朋友凯文还有凯莉聊这个，她，我不知道。凯文和凯莉，播客的朋友。是的，没错，我们所有人。所以，是的，但是他们，我不知道，我们聊到了分娩这个话题。
kind of lay out where you find yourself on a YouTube search and then specifically for childbirth? Because I was talking to my friend Kevin about it and Carrie and she, and I don't know. Kevin and Carrie, friends of the podcast. Yeah, that's correct, and all of us. So yeah, but they, I don't know, we got on the subject of childbirth.
哦，因为我的一个朋友，因为我的一个朋友，我们的一个朋友，刚生了个孩子，克里斯·帕拉特和凯瑟琳·施瓦辛格生了个男孩，取名叫福特。是的，恭喜他们。等等，我们需要，我们需要送份礼物。我们得送他们点什么。你觉得他们有登记礼单吗？
Oh, because a friend of mine, because a friend of mine, a friend of ours, just had a baby and Chris Pratt and Catherine Schwarzenegger had a baby boy named Ford. Yes, congrats to them. Wait, do we need to, we need to send a gift. We gotta send them something. Do you think they're registered?
送点SmartList的周边吧。不，我要写上我的名字。我要写上你们的名字。我送了点东西，但我会写上你们的名字。谢谢。所以你看了分娩过程，你的反应是什么？不，我当时在和别人聊这个，我说，哇，我的意思是，我不知道。
Some smart little swag. No, I'll put my name on it. I'll put your names on it. I sent something, but I'll put your names on it. Thanks. So you saw the childbirth and what was your reaction? No, so I was talking to people about it and I was like, wow, I mean, I'd know.
它是从那里出来的？我完全不知道看着它真的，从那里出来，医生就在旁边。头出来的时候是拉长的。是的，是的，整个身体都出来了。我第一次看的时候，以为出了什么问题。我当时在场，见证了我三个儿子的出生。哦哇，真是个好爸爸。
It comes out of there? I had no idea that to watch it actually being, to come out and the doctor right there. And the head comes out all elongated. Yes, yes, and the whole body comes out. First time I saw it, I thought something was wrong. I was there for the birth of all three of my boys. Oh wow, what a dad.
而且他们是。三个都是。三个都是剖腹产。这……这很难看下去。确实，这就是我想说的。你把整个市场都清空了。伙计，我当时想，是的，这会很有趣。
And they were. All three. All three were, were cesesarean C-sections. Which was- That's tough to watch. It is, that was my point. You empty out the whole market there. Dude, and I'm like, yeah it's gonna be fun.
我记得你第一次说，这会很有趣，然后看着，只是说，哦，哦，哦。胃、肠子、脾脏、肝脏，所有东西都在桌子上。顺便问一下，你知道什么是“白金同性恋”吗？就是生出来后发现是同性恋的孩子，他甚至没经过产道，是剖腹产出来的。
I remember the first time you're like, it's gonna be fun and then looking and just going, oh, oh, oh. Stomach, intestine, spleen, liver, everything on the table. By the way, you know what a platinum gay is? A baby that comes out who turns out to be gay who never even went through the canal, had a C-section.
所以不仅没被碰过、看过，甚至没经过那里。这就是“白金同性恋”。这是个真实术语吗？白金同性恋。意思是你的妈妈做了剖腹产。Grindr上有一个专门的板块吗？那是另一回事吗？
So not only once touched, looked at it, or been through it. Is a platinum gay. That's a real term? Platinum gay. Means your mom had a C-section. Is that a whole section on Grindr? Is that a different? All rightr? Is that a different?
好了，说到这儿，我们要请出我们的嘉宾了。好的。伙计们。这怎么可能？伙计们，我们很少在节目中邀请军人。更罕见的是英国军人。今天我们请到了一位皇家海军指挥官，好吗？但这不仅仅是一名士兵。
All right, and with that, we'll get to our guest. Okay. Guys. How is that possible? Guys, we rarely have members of the military on the show. Even more rare are members of the British military. Today we have a commander of the Royal Navy, all right? But this is not just a soldier.
他的兴趣包括橄榄球。是丘吉尔吗？扫雷。我现在得重来了。你知道我不喜欢在我的……我花了很多时间写这些。伙计们，我们很少在节目中邀请军人。更罕见的是英国军人。
His interests include rugby. Is it Churchill? Clearing. I'm gonna have to start over now. You know I don't like to be interrupted during my, I spent a long time writing these. Guys, we rarely have members of the military on this show. Even more rare are members of the British military.
今天我们请到了一位皇家海军指挥官。但这不仅仅是一名士兵。他的兴趣包括橄榄球、扫雷、莎士比亚、利物浦足球、威尔、解谜和摇匀马提尼。伙计们？什么？是丹尼尔·克雷格。
Today we have a commander of the Royal Navy. But this is not just a soldier. His interests include rugby, clearing minefields, Shakespeare, Liverpool soccer, Will, solving mysteries and shaking martinis. Guys? What? It's Daniel Craig.
不会吧！呜！是的，是的，是的。天哪，我太想见你了。就在那儿。这太酷了。好吧，我们在这儿了。威尔，放轻松。
No way! Woo! Yep, yep, yep. Oh my God, I wanted to meet you for so long. Right there. This is so cool. Well, here we are. Will, take it easy.
好吧，我知道，我不知道你是利物浦的支持者。这是个好消息。你们见面的时候没聊过这个吗？是的，我应该聊过的。等等，丹尼尔，我想我知道你住哪个酒店房间了。你一直在这个酒店房间里。你在洛杉矶四季酒店。
Well, I know, I didn't know that you were a Liverpool supporter. This is great news. You would have covered that before when you guys met? Yeah, I would have. Wait, Daniel, I think I know what hotel room you're in. You've been in this hotel room. You're at the Four Seasons Los Angeles.
你是怎么猜到的？是真的吗？因为你在参加媒体见面会，对吧？你在参加媒体见面会？是的。我来这家酒店大概有35年了。同一个房间。他们一直安排同一个房间。
How did you guess? Is that true? Because you're on a junket, right? You're on a junket? Yeah. I've been coming to this hotel for like 35 years. Same room. They're doing the same room.
丹尼尔，他们做这件夹克是男款的吗？嘿，肖恩。哇。这是最初的几分钟。我们开始了。好。太棒了。我其实很喜欢它。我其实很喜欢它。
Daniel, did they make that jacket and men's or? Hey, Sean. Wow. This is one of the first minutes. And we're off. Good. Excellent. I actually love it. I actually love it.
我其实很喜欢它。等等。现在，肖恩。不，不，不。我其实真的很喜欢这件格子衫。肖恩，你也认识丹尼尔吗？我不认识。我显然从来没见过你。
I actually love it. Wait. Now, Sean. No, no, no. I actually really like the check. Sean, do you know Daniel as well? I don't. I've never met you, obviously.
我是个超级粉丝。看起来不像。不。非常随意。我是个超级，超级粉丝。超级粉丝。我不能，是的。好的。
I'm a massive. It doesn't seem like it. No. Very casual. I'm a massive, massive fan. Massive fan. I can't, yeah. OK.
威尔，你见过克雷格先生。我们见过。我们一起玩过。我们一起看了超级碗，对吧，好的，威尔你见过克雷格先生，我们见过，我们一起玩过，我们一起看了超级碗，对吧丹尼尔。是的，我们看了。然后我们去了城堡酒店。是的，那是之后吗？我不记得了，那是，是的，我有过几次经历，但可能没有。不，是同一天。我知道我们，是的，我们最后和克拉辛斯基还有肖恩·潘在城堡酒店。这就是为什么我不能，我已经喝醉了，该死的，好莱坞，这太好莱坞了，听起来像个段子，但实际上，是的，那是很久以前的事了，很棒的酒友，我当时在哪儿，该死，在某个设施里，我
And Will, you have met Mr. Craig. We have met. We hung out. We watched the Super Bowl together, right, okay, and will you have met mr. Craig we have met we hung out we had we watched the Super Bowl together Right Daniel. Yes, we did And then we went and end up in the chateau. Yes Yeah, is that way it was that after I can't remember that's yeah, I've been incidents, but there's probably no No, it was the same night. I know that we yeah, we ended up in chateau with krasinski and Sean Penn That's why I can't i'm drunk already fucking hollywood it's just it was a lot it was very hollywood it sounds like a bit but it's actually yeah that was a long time ago great group to drink with where was i damn it in a facility i was
可能在某个设施里处理事情。我想那是贝蒂·福特中心的家庭周末。嗯，现在，肖恩，我们要聊到丹尼尔在《星球大战》里演冲锋队的时候了。我们要聊到那个。我知道他演的是哪一个。怎么样？真的吗？
probably in a facility somewhere figuring stuff out. It was, I think it was family weekend at Betty Ford. Um, now, Sean, we're gonna get, Sean, we're gonna get to the time when Daniel was a stormtrooper in Star Wars. We're gonna get to that. I know exactly which one he was. How about that? Truly?
我当然知道。所以这不是我刚在维基百科上发现的。不，就是那个她说，她施展心灵控制，然后你说你会走开并放下武器。我会走开并放下武器。你放下了武器，你走出了那个场景。
Of course I do. So this is not something that I just discovered on Wikipedia. No, it's the one where he says, where she plays the mind trick, and you will walk away and drop your weapon. I will walk away and drop my weapon. You dropped your weapon, you walked out of the scene.
是真的。是真的。你说话了。嗯，我不想，但我只是说，给我配音吧，看在上帝的份上，我不需要，但我不得不等。但那是个小角色，你知道，你作为冲锋队说话，那是个有台词的角色。
It's true. It's true. You spoke. Well, I didn't want to, but I just said, dub me, Christ's sake, I don't need, but then I had to wait. But that's a bump, you know, you speak as a storm trooper, that's a bump into principle.
你觉得我拿到了吗？是的，我敢打赌。他们甚至没给我制服。我唯一想要的就是制服。就像，至少给我个头盔。那是怎么发生的？你相信吗？你是去片场参观，
Do you think I got one? Yeah, I'll bet. They didn't even give me the uniform. The only thing I wanted was the uniform. It was like, give me the helmet, at least. How did that come about? What do you believe? Were you visiting on the set,
然后他们说，这儿有个临时演员？我们正要开始，是哪部邦德电影你记不清了？不，不，不是，那是很久以前的事了，一定是《幽灵党》，因为我当时在准备，我知道那些人，我知道所有的剧组人员，助理导演都在工作。你溜到了舞台上。真的吗？
and they said, here's an extra? We were about to start Which bond it was you lose track? No, no, it wasn't no it was way before that was it must have been specter because I was and we were prepping and I Knew the guys were I knew all the crew the the A.D.s worked on You drifted over to the stage Really?
然后我有点说，哦，来吧，给我找套新制服。是的，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。来吧，真的，事情是这样发生的吗？完全是这样，他们就像，我半开玩笑地以为他们只是会告诉我从哪儿滚蛋，但我当时想。
And then I kind of went, oh, come on, go get me a new uniform. Yeah, I love that. I love that. Come on, truly, is that the way that it went? It went exactly, and they were like, I was half joking thinking they were just going to tell me where to get off, but I was like.
那一天有多长？太他妈长了。是的。你知道，那种后悔，就像，有点想，哦不，我会当个临时演员，哦耶，这太棒了。哦，你待了多少个小时？我要坐在镜头后面。就像，他们非常好。他们很棒。
How long of a day was that? Too fucking long. Yeah. You know, that kind of regret of like, sort of think, oh no, I'll be an extra, oh yeah, it's great. Oh, how many hours were you being? I'm going to sit in the back of shot for this. It's like, they were very good. They were great.
我确实记得，因为你知道，那些套装，我的意思是，它们基本上是硬塑料，而且有点，你知道，它们不舒服。我的意思是，天知道他们在沙漠里拍那些戏时是怎么穿的。但我记得它对我来说有点大，它压在我的拇指上，我的拇指在之后的三天里都是麻的。
I do remember when, cause you know, those, the suits are, I mean, they're basically hard plastic and kind of, you know, they're not comfortable. I mean, God knows how they wore them out in the desert when they do those. But I remember that it sort of was a little bit big for me and it sort of rested on my thumb and my thumb was numb for three days afterwards.
因为我当时想，我付出的代价，而且我没拿到台词。对。没台词，没头盔，什么都没有。你在城堡酒店拿到了台词。呃。呃。肖恩想知道，你见过塔图因的市长吗？该死，成熟点，肖恩想知道，你见过塔图因的市长吗？该死，成熟点，肖恩。
Because I was like, the price I pay, and I didn't get a bump. Right. No bump, no helmet, no nothing. You got a bump at the Chateau. Ew. Ew. Sean wants to know, did you meet the mayor of Tatooine? Fucking grow up, Sean wants to know, did you meet the mayor of Tatooine? Fucking grow up, Sean.
我会杀了他。我知道他会绕回这个话题的。好了，现在，丹尼尔……丹尼尔在哪儿……你有所有的问题吗？我有好多，是的。而这两个家伙只会捣乱，阻止你回答问题。事情就是这样。事情就是这样。
I would kill him. He's going to double back to this, I know it. Alright, now, Daniel... Where does Daniel... Do you have all the questions? I've got so many, yeah. And these two just fuck with you and stop you answering the questions. That's the way it goes. That's the way it goes.
是的。你能说话就不错了。当揭晓的时候，另外两个说，哦该死。那肯定会发生，当然。确实。确实。发生过，虽然没大声说出来。是的。
Yeah. You'll be lucky to speak. What happens when the reveal and the other two go, oh fuck. That must happen, sure. It does. It does. It's happened not out loud. Yeah.
是的。好了，现在让我们，我们可以，我要先声明一下，我敢打赌，我会问你一些你已经回答过一千遍的问题，我希望你能对我们保持耐心，因为我们是没做足功课的笨蛋，我们不是记者。我们是糟糕的采访者。
Yeah. Yeah. All right, now let's just, can we, I'm going to qualify this by saying, I'll bet, I'm going to ask you some questions that you've answered a thousand times, and I want you to be patient with us, because we're dumb people that aren't fully researched, we're not journalists. We're terrible interviewers.
我们只会问你一些愚蠢的问题，好吗？为什么我觉得我被忽悠了？欢迎来到Smarland。现在，关于……我们可以从头开始吗？当然。好吧，好吧。所以你在利物浦，对吧？是的。
We're just going to come at you with just dumb questions, okay? Why do I feel like I'm being hustled here? Welcome to Smarland. Now, what about... Can we start at the beginning? Sure. Alright, alright. So you're in Liverpool, alright? Yes.
顺便说一下，你得看看丹尼尔……想象一下那个场景。好吧，天是灰的。是的。下着雨。那么，那里有什么影响吗？妈妈还是爸爸？妈妈。妈妈是个……
By the way, you gotta see Daniel... Picture the scene. Okay, so it's gray. Yeah. It's pissing with rain. Now, was there an influence there? Mom or dad? Mom. Mom was a...
艺术老师。艺术老师，谢谢。哦哇，那太酷了。所以她让你接触了一些艺术。她带你去看电影或戏剧之类的。火花是怎么产生的？戏剧是关键。当时利物浦有个剧院，
An art teacher. Art teacher, thank you. Oh wow, that's cool. And so she sort of exposed you to the arts a little bit. She took you to movies or to plays or whatnot. How did the spark start? Plays were the thing. There was a theater in Liverpool at the time,
现在还在，叫Everyman剧院，在七十年代，那是人才的温床。但她的朋友们都在利物浦艺术学院，他们很多人都进入了剧院，从事舞台设计之类的，那些就是她的朋友。她是个单亲妈妈。我们过去常常几乎每天晚上都去那里，
the seventh still is called the Everyman Theatre, which was a really, was kind of a hotbed of talent, as they say, at the time in the seventies. But her friends had been at Liverpool Art College and a lot of them had gone into the theatre, stage design, and those things, and those were her kind of friends. She was a single mum. And we used to kind of end up going there most nights
去剧院只是为了闲逛。那里有一种，他们有个小酒馆。太酷了。提供廉价食物。那是一个受补贴的剧院，他们做了一件事，就像，你知道，票价是一英镑，那是一个受补贴的剧院，他们做了一件事，就像，票价是一英镑。就像整个事情的初衷是
to the theatre just to sort of hang out. There was a kind of, they had a bistro there. That's so cool. That served up cheap food. And it was a subsidised theatre, and they did this thing where it was like, you know, there was a pound, a ticket, it was a subsidized theater, and they did this thing where it was like, there was a pound, a ticket. It was like the whole thing was supposed to be
为了让每个人都负担得起。他们演了一些非常棒的戏，这意味着我晚上都在剧院后台度过。那会改变你的。是的。好吧，那是所有乐趣发生的地方。是的，这是妈妈真的很喜欢的东西，
so everybody could afford to go. And they did some off the charts plays, but it meant that I spent sort of evenings backstage at the theater. And that'll do it to you. Yeah. Well, that's where all the fun happened. Yeah, and this is something that mom really likes,
看起来很酷，等等等等，对吧？你知道，演员们就像，你知道，之后会见演员，我看着他们，我以为他们是神，然后我意识到他们喝醉了。是的，他们喝醉了。这是必要的组成部分。但他们喝醉了，但与此同时，
it seems pretty cool, and on and on and on, right? And you know, actors kind of like, you know, meet actors afterwards, I'm seeing them, and I thought they were gods, and then I just realized they were drunk. Yeah, they were drunk. It's a necessary component. But they were drunk, but at the same time,
在那个年纪，如果你很年轻，你是青少年，无论是什么，当你接触到那种东西和那个世界时，它确实给了你其他同龄孩子没有的视角。你花了很多时间和有才华、有创造力的成年人在一起。
at that age, at that age, if you're quite young and you're an adolescent, you're a teenager, whatever it is, when you're exposed to that kind of thing in that kind of world, it does give you that perspective that other kids your age don't have. And you're spending a lot of time with adults who are talented, who are creative.
当那种火花在那个年纪被点燃时，我觉得这很酷。是的，我的意思是，绝对。我的意思是，它真的进去了。那就是我想做的。我的意思是，那是我唯一想做的。但它也给了我这个，不仅是观察剧院的工作方式和专业人士的工作方式，
And when you get that fire kind of sparked at that age, I think it's pretty cool. Yeah, I mean, definitely. And I mean, it really did, it went in. That's what I wanted to do. I mean, that's all I wanted to do. But it also gave me this, it's not only watching the way a theater works and the way that professionals work and all that,
它也让我觉得，哦，这也是一份工作。你可以看到这一点。这是几件事。你知道，很多事情发生了。你第一次想到“哦，这可能是我不会让自己出丑的事情”是什么时候？你第一次想到我可能……那还没发生。
it also kind of went, oh, this is a job as well. You can see that. It's kind of a couple of things. You know, lots of things happen. When was the first time you thought, oh, this is something that I might not embarrass myself doing? When was the first time you thought I might... That hasn't happened.
你在说什么？第二部邦德电影，第二部邦德电影。喝酒的成分对此有帮助。我仍然觉得我在让自己出丑。但我的意思是，是在学校戏剧里你觉得，哦，我不烂，或者我得到了一些赞扬吗？我被拉进了一部学校戏剧。
What are you talking about? Second Bond film, second Bond film. The drinking component helps with that. I still feel like I'm embarrassing myself. But I mean, was it a school play where you're like, oh, I don't suck at this, or I'm getting a couple of pats on the back? I got roped into a school play.
我的意思是，我做了那种事，我想我可能请了几天假之类的，我得了腮腺炎还是什么，我不知道。我回来后就被选进了学校戏剧。就像，哦。是什么，你还记得是什么吗？是《雾都孤儿》，是的，我当时想，哦哇。是Sowersbury先生，我不是奥利弗。
I mean, I kind of did one of those things where I think I kind of had a couple of days off or whatever, I got the mumps or something, I don't know. And I came back and I'd been cast in the school play. And it was like, oh. What was it, do you remember what it was? It was Oliver, yeah, and I was like, oh wow. It was Mr. I wasn't Oliver.
遗憾的是。我是Sowersbury先生，那个角色在电影里没有，但在音乐剧里有，而且有充分的理由，被从电影里删掉了。但他是个辛辣的角色吗？他是个殡仪员。你得偷一两个钱包，对吧？我没能做到，不，遗憾的是，是的。你得偷一两个钱包，那是
Sadly. I was Mr. Sowersbury, which is the part that's not in the movie that kind of was in the musical and got, for good reason, got written out of the movie. Was it a spicy character though? He's an undertaker. You got to pick a pocket or two, right? I didn't get to do that, no, sadly, yeah. You got to pick a pocket or two, that's I didn't get to do that, no, sadly, yeah. You gotta pick a pocket or two, that's right.
这是你信奉的信条。好吧，所以你做了那个，你得到了一些赞扬，一些拍拍背，你就像，好吧，我会稍微倾向于这个，你开始可能稍微多一点……好吧，我不知道你们怎么样，我的意思是，你们一定都在某个时候演过学校戏剧。这只是一种群体歇斯底里的事情，
I mean, it's a credo you live by. Right, so you do that, you get a couple of atta boys, a couple of pats on the back, and you're like, all right, well, I'm gonna lean into this a little bit, and you started maybe a little bit more sort of like... Well, I don't know about you guys, I mean, you must have all done a school play at some point. It's just that kind of mass hysteria thing
那种发生了，我的意思是，我的孩子们演学校戏剧，我喜欢那种，就像那种程度的，哦天哪！这就像，它会留在你身边，它会，你懂的。太对了。我被要求参加学校戏剧，我想是因为，我很确定，
that kind of happens, which is, I mean, my kids do school plays, I love that kind of, just like the level of like, oh my God! Which is like, it kind of stays with you, it kind of, you get it. That's so true. I got asked to be in the school play and I think it was because, I'm quite sure,
从未完全证实，我很确定是因为我是一个大嘴巴，讨厌鬼。不。什么？不。不。是的，如果你能相信的话。他们就像，该死，我们怎么，有没有什么地方我们可以找到一个隔音的房间，或者我们可以带走的地方
never totally confirmed, quite sure it was because I was such a loud mouth, pain in the ass. No. What? No. No. Yeah, if you can believe it. And they were like, fuck, how do we, is there somewhere we can find like either a room that's soundproof or somewhere we can take
那种让每个人都发疯的能量。顺便说一下，顺便说一下，威尔的。他们就像《皮纳福号军舰》，我当时想，好吧。是的，就是这样。好吧，同样的事情，同样的事情。人们就像，天哪，你太吵了，太烦人了。是的。是的，我演了莎士比亚的《第十二夜》，
that fucking energy that's driving everybody crazy. By the way, by the way, Willie's. And they're like HMS Pinafore and I was like, okay. Yeah, that's it. Well, the same thing, the same thing. People were like, God, you're fucking loud and annoying. Yeah. Yeah, and I did Shakespeare's 12th Night,
我演了安德鲁·阿吉切克爵士。我完全不知道我在说什么。直到我站在观众面前，然后它就点击了，每一句喜剧台词都得到了笑声，我当时想，那是什么？那是什么？那是关于什么的？
and I was Sir Andrew Aguichig. I had no idea what I was saying. And until I got in front of the audience, then it kind of clicked, and every line that was a comedy line got a laugh, and I was like, what is that? What is that? What is that about?
是的，那太疯狂了。当你开始感觉到的时候。是的，是的。你想避免的终极毒品。是的，我当时想，去你的，这个大嘴巴会继续下去。现在丹尼尔，你非常，非常有趣。就像，你知道，《利刃出鞘》，不，那个《利刃出鞘》的东西
Yeah, that's crazy. When you started feeling that. Yeah, yeah. The ultimate drug you wanted to avoid. Yeah, I'm like, fuck you, this loudmouth's gonna keep going. Now Daniel, you are very, very funny. Like, you know, the knife out, no, the knife out stuff
太棒了。然后当有人说你非常，非常，非常有趣。我可以问，是吗？不，但也许是因为人们没预料到，因为你做了那么多不可思议的戏剧性工作。我15年来一直很忧郁。是的，我的意思是，我们得到什么就做什么，你知道吗？但现在，你开始追求，举手，
is like awesome. And then when someone says you're very, very, very funny. I can say, am I? No, but maybe it's because people weren't expecting because you've done so much incredible dramatic work. I've been so moody for 15 years. Yeah, I mean, we do what we get, you know? But now, are you starting to pursue, raise your hand,
得到更多喜剧剧本，这是让你兴奋的事情吗？请说是的。我从来没，是的，好的，是的。是的，如果可以的话，为什么你不给我问题，我只是，什么答案？我确实构建了问题的答案。答案总是内置的，所以他喜欢
get more scripts that are more comedic and is that something that is exciting to you? Please say yes. I never, yes, okay, yes. Yes, if you can, why don't you give me the questions and I'll just, what answers? I do build the answer to the question. The answer is always built in and so then he likes
把嘉宾带入不可避免的非常有趣的“是”或“否”。我们就是这样结束的吗？我等不及了。五十个问题，是或否。这很容易。所以你想做更多喜剧？是的。
to bring the guest into the inevitable really interesting yes or no. Is that how we go out on this? I can't wait. Fifty questions yes or no. It's easy. So you want to do more comedy? Yes.
听着，就像我有计划一样。对，是的，是的。我的意思是，我边走边编。我不知道那个。我的意思是，认真地说，就像，如果它们来了，当然，但我有点出去寻找有趣的东西。这也是，我知道那种做这件事是多么危险，你知道，就像，第一晚出去，
Listen, it would be like I had a plan. Right, yeah, yeah. I mean, I'm making this up as I go along. I don't know about that. I mean, seriously, it's like, if they come along, sure, but I'm kind of going out and looking for something funny. It's also, I know how kind of that's a dangerous thing to do, you know, it's like, the first night out,
我读了剧本，我大声笑了出来，我说了该死。我的意思是，那是一个简单，简单的选择。然后莱恩是现有的最有才华的作家之一。他只是继续前进，继续努力，继续深入。而下一部会不同。我们已经有点，我的意思是，它不是完全不同，
I read the script and I laughed out loud and I went fuck. I mean that was like an easy, easy pick. And then Ryan's one of the most talented writers there are. He just kind of keeps going and keeps getting at it and keeps getting into it. And this next one's gonna be different. And we've kind of gone, I mean it's not wildly different,
但它肯定会有一种不同的基调。哦等等，你现在在拍第三部吗？我们在峰会上拍了第三部。它叫《唤醒死者》。哦哇。哇。就像在为电影做广告。
but it's gonna be definitely kind of get a different tone to it. Oh wait, there's a third one you're doing now? There's a third one we shot at the summit. It's called Wake Up, Deadman. Oh wow. Wow. It's like plugging the movie.
是的。是的，不，不，请。是的，来吧。是的。对，但我的意思是你说没有，就像你有什么计划之类的，但我会猜，一个被邀请参加像邦德这样标志性项目的人，
Yeah. Yeah, no, no, please. Yeah, come on. Yeah. Right, but I mean you say that there's no, like that you have some sort of a plan or something, but I would guess that somebody who is approached for something as iconic as Bond
以及你拥有的那种智慧，你可能有一些想法，并与一些人谈论过，好吧，如果我做了这个，我必须做这个，但如果我做了这个，我需要有一个计划，如何在那些电影之间占据自己，以及之后做什么。我只是搞砸了。
and the kind of intelligence that you have, you probably had some thoughts and some talks with some people about, okay, if I did this, I've got to do this, but if I did this, I would need to kind of have a plan how to occupy myself in between those movies and what to do afterwards. Which I just fucked up.
我不这么认为。我不这么认为。我认为这很完美。我们很快会聊到《酷儿》，这是一个完美的平衡。顺便说一下，你不需要为任何事情做计划。我想我们现在就要聊到它们了。继续吧。
I don't think so. I don't think so. I think it's kind of perfect. We're going to get to Queer soon, which is a perfect balance. By the way, you didn't need to plan for anything. I guess we're going to get to them right now. Go ahead.
这是我们的片段。继续吧，肖恩。不，我要说的是，你不需要计划，因为那些电影太他妈累人了，我肯定。是的。你不需要恢复吗？我想当我刚开始时有一种感觉，因为我正好有了你说的那些对话，我和我认识的每个人、我的家人以及所有关于这意味着什么的事情谈过。我当然必须做。我必须做这个，但这意味着什么，那些对话。我和我认识的每个人、我的家人以及所有关于这意味着什么的事情谈过，
There's our clip. Go ahead, Sean. No, I was going to say, you didn't need to plan because those movies were fucking exhausting, I'm sure. Yeah. Didn't you need to recover? I think there was a feeling when I first started that because I'd had exactly what you said, those conversations, and I talked about it to everybody I knew and my family and all of those things about what does it mean. Of course I've got to do it. I've got to do this, but what does it, those conversations. And I talked about it to everybody I knew, and all my family, and all of those things about what does it mean, of course I've got to do it,
我必须做这个，但这意味着什么？我的意思是，它将如何影响我的生活，以及所有这些事情。我猜我内心有一种本能，想要去，好吧，我在做邦德，现在我也必须做其他事情来平衡这一点。这简直是太他妈荒谬了。
I've got to do this, but what does it mean? I mean, how it's going to affect my life, and all those things. And there was a sort of, I suppose, an instinct in me to sort of want to go, okay, I'm doing Bon and now I've got to do other stuff as well to kind of counterbalance this. It's just like fucking ridiculous.
这简直是，我的意思是，就像，我他妈累坏了。我当时想，所以我中间拍的电影，我有点引以为豪，所有这些事情，我停下来，我只是去，只做这个。如果我在做这个，就只做这个。我没有头脑空间。我没有，我的意思是。我要说一些将要，
It's just like, I mean, it's like, I was fucking exhausted. I was like, so as much as the moves I did in between, I'm kind of like proud of and all of those things, I stopped, I just went, just do this. If I'm doing this, just do this. And I don't have the head space. I don't have the, I mean. I'm going to say something that's going to be,
这不是争议性的，但我知道因为邦德粉丝在邦德世界里是如此，那些粉丝是如此直言不讳和专注，等等。但我会说，对我来说，我喜欢所有之前的邦德，每个人都很棒。所以这绝不是对他们所做事情的指责。但你是第一个像真正的男人中的男人的邦德。是的，性感。
it's not controversial, but I know because the Bond fans in the Bond world is so, those fans are so vocal and dedicated, et cetera. But I will say that for me, and I loved all the prior Bonds, everybody was great. So this is by no means an admonishment of what they had done. But you were the first Bond who was like a real like, real man's man. Yeah, piece of ass.
而且很强硬。你很强硬。这是有争议的，哪里有争议了？是的，完全正确。好吧，不，但你来了，你很强硬，因为我认为人们会说，你怎么敢，等等等等。但你出来了，你就像这个强硬的，
And was tough. You were tough. This is controversial, where's it getting controversial? Yeah, exactly. Well no, but you came, you were tough, and because I think that people will go like, how dare you, blah, blah, blah. But you came out and you were like this tough,
就像你是一个真正的现代邦德，我觉得这真的，真的很令人耳目一新。我喜欢你的邦德电影，伙计。我真的喜欢。绝对，谢谢。是的，是的。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。
like you were like a real modern Bond in a way that I thought was really, really refreshing. I loved your Bond films, dude. I really did. Absolutely, thank you. Yeah, yeah. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
我的问题是，当你拍第一部时，我已经看过十亿遍了，我所有电影都看过十亿遍。我真的可以像里面的对话一样。我知道我看过十亿遍了。好的，来吧。给我。停，你说了什么？
My question is when you were doing the very first one, which I've seen a billion times, I've seen all of them a billion times. I literally could do like dialogue from it. I know I've seen it a billion times. Okay, go. Give it to me. Stop, what did you say?
把你的手从耳朵上拿开。总之，那是第一部。总之，所以谢谢，谢谢。问题。呃。但等等，在什么点？那也是我记得的台词。继续吧。
Take your hand away from your ear. Anyway, that was the first one. Anyway, so thank you, thank you. Question. Uh. But wait, at what point? That would have been the line I remembered too. Go ahead.
我昨天真的刚说过。它是标志性的。它更好。但等等。去直升机那儿，对吧？它和那个并列。但等等，丹尼尔。当你拍那部电影时，在什么点。
I literally just said it yesterday. It's iconic. It's better. But wait. Get to the choppas, right? It's up there with that. But wait, Daniel. At what point when you were making that move.
抱歉，我想我的电话在响。不，那引发了整个追逐。把你的手拿过来。但总之，所以当你拍那部电影时，在电影中间的什么点你觉得，哦天哪，我咬得太多了，这真的很难。就像，我不知道我是否能成功。
Sorry, I think my phone's ringing. No, that kicked off the whole chase. Get your hand over here. But anyway, so when you were doing that movie, at what point in the middle of the movie were you like, oh God, I bit off more than I could chew, this is really hard. Like, I don't know if I'm going to make it.
或者你觉得，哦，这太棒了，我可以做到。所有的特技，你所经历的所有废话，你让你的身体经历的一切。我的意思是，我当时比较年轻，我太拼了。是的，是的，是的。我只是，你知道，我的意思是，我有点投入自己。有，你知道，那些家伙有点说，你知道，你想做，是的，我会做，是的！
Or were you like, oh, this is awesome, I can do this. All the stunts, all the bullshit that you had, that you put your body through. I mean, I was sort of younger and I'm way too gung ho. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I was just, you know, I mean, I kind of threw myself. There was, you know, the guys were kind of saying, you know, do you want to do, yeah, I'll do, yeah!
我当时想，是的，然后我们就像，是的，我知道。但我有所有这些事情发生。我们开始在布拉格的摄影棚拍摄，然后我们搬到了巴哈马，然后我的经纪人，他非常好，但我的经纪人打电话给我说，你可能想看看互联网，互联网刚刚爆炸了。
I was like, yeah, and then we were like, yeah, I know. But I had all this stuff going on. We started shooting in Prague, in studios there, and then we moved to the Bahamas, and then my agent, which was very nice, but then my agent phoned me up and said, you might want to look at the internet, and the internet has just sort of blown up.
我做了这个，像，去他的，那种事情。是的，是的，我记得那个。这有点像，我看着这一切，就像，你知道，当，天真的日子里我过去常做那种事，就像哦不，我要看这一切，然后掉进那个兔子洞，整晚追逐它，就像哦天哪，
I've done this like, fuck him, kind of thing. Yeah, yeah, I remember that. Which was kind of like, and I kind of looked at it all and as like, you know, when, the naive days when I used to do stuff like that, like oh no, I'm going to look at all and go down that rabbit hole and just chased it all night long and was like oh my god,
那真的很强烈，我有点，我然后有点只是有这种，某种，我不知道，我只是有点去，好吧，去他的，我对此无能为力。我无能为力，我们在这儿，我知道剧本很好，让我们玩得开心。如果这是一个挥棒落空，太棒了。如果这是我的最后一部，我会走开，知道
that's really intense and I kind of, I then sort of just had this sort of like, sort of, I don't know, I just sort of went, well, fuck all I can do about that. There's nothing I can do, and we're here, and I know the script's good, and let's have a good time. And if it's a swing and a miss, great. If it's my last one, I'll walk away knowing
我尽了全力。我的意思是，它听起来现在说很容易。但它只是，它就像，我当时想，让我们继续吧。让我们做吧。我只是，你知道。你认为，你认为，那种火的洗礼，因为邦德再次如此标志性，通过被置于最明亮的聚光灯下并被如此多地审视，在社交媒体上或在线上，你认为那是一个，你能够把那些教训带到邦德之后和你的正常生活中吗？
that I did the best I could. I mean, it kind of, it sounds easy to say now. But it just, it was like, it just, I was like, let's get on with this. Let's do it. I just, you know. And do you think, do you think that, that sort of that trial by fire of, of being, because Bond again is so iconic and by being put in the brightest of spotlights and being scrutinized so much, sort of on social media or whatever it is online, do you think that that was a, were you able to carry those lessons on sort of post bond and in your normal life?
所以当你，因为我们有时谈论它，人们在社交媒体上说什么的反应，每个人都有声音之类的，每个人都把它放在不同的地方或以不同的方式处理它。它如何影响你的生活？你考虑过吗？我的意思是，我认为名声的事情，我的意思是，它出来后我完全精神崩溃了，大概六个月没出家门。真的吗？我的意思是，我的意思是，我夸张了，但我有点那样。我只是觉得，哦天哪，我的意思是，它就像，这是一种名声和可识别性，不是一个人能快速且容易处理的事情。好吧，你和谁谈论它？
So as you, because we talk about it sometimes, what's the reaction to what people say in social media and everybody's got a voice and stuff and everybody kind of puts it in a different place or deals with it differently. How does it affect your life? Do you think about it? I mean, I think the fame thing, I mean, I just had a complete nervous breakdown after it came out and sort of didn't leave the house for six months. Really? I mean, I mean, I exaggerate, but I kind of was a bit like that. I just got like, oh my, I mean, it was like, It's a level of fame and recognizability that is not something that one deals with quickly and easily. Well, and how do you talk to about it?
我的意思是，我想你去，我要给某个非常，非常有名的人打电话。我的意思是，就像，我不知道你说什么。是的，或者如果你和屠夫或你的朋友或某个没工作的人谈，他们就像，哦呜呜，你是詹姆斯·邦德，对吧？完全正确，完全正确。对，所以那种健康的冷漠在哪里
I mean, I suppose you go, I'm going to phone up someone really, really famous. I mean, it's like, I don't know what you say. Yeah, or if you talked to the butcher or your friend or somebody who's not working and they're like, oh boo-hoo, you're James Bond, right? Exactly, exactly. Right, so where does that healthy level of indifference
关于它是否有效，我仍然会做我自己，如果它不，或者这种名声的事情，就像，是你的，妈妈给了你一个好头脑，还是它有点，你是自学的？我想有一个，我只是有一个非常，你知道，脚踏实地的家庭，他们不回避告诉我我是一个多么低级的人。
come from about whether it works or not and I'm going to still just be me and if it doesn't or this fame stuff, like, was your, did mom give you a good head on your shoulders or was it sort of, were you kind of self-taught? I think there's a, I've just got a very, you know, down to earth family who do not shy away from telling me what a low life I am.
我的意思是，这真的有帮助。而且只是，是的，来自，我不知道，我来自英格兰北部，这是一种更，你知道，实用，务实的生活方式。我也很早就进入了那个阶段，我去了戏剧学校，戏剧学校有一件可怕的事情，就是90%的人没工作。这就是流失率
I mean it's like, and that really helps. And just, yeah, coming, I don't know, I'm from the north of England, it's a more kind of like sort of practical sort of pragmatic way of looking at life maybe. I also got into that thing of very early on, I went to drama school and there's that terrible thing of drama school is that like 90% of the year don't get to work. It's like that's the attrition rate
你进入这个行业，没有社交媒体，所以没有其他渠道试图出名。只是你得到了一份工作或者你没得到一份工作，大多数人没得到工作。我知道有人在戏剧学校时给了我一个很好的建议，一位伟大的导演只是说，永远，永远，永远不要变得痛苦。不要变得，你知道，因为痛苦只是那种
and you go into the business, there wasn't social media so there wasn't another outlet to try and become famous. It was just like you got a job or you didn't get a job and mostly people didn't get a job. I know that somebody gave me a great bit of advice very early on while at drama school, a great director who just said, don't ever, ever, ever get bitter. Don't get, you know, because bitterness is just the thing
它会吞噬你，因为总有人会得到工作或超过你。总有人会，你知道，如果你只带着嫉妒看行业里的其他人，那就会定义你。没关系，如果你后来成功了，你仍然会有点，我一直很嫉妒，
that it'll just eat you up, because there's always somebody gonna get the job or the bug put over you. There's always somebody gonna, you know, and if you kind of only look at other people in the business with jealousy, then that'll define you. And it doesn't matter if you then get success, you'll still kind of, I get jealous all the time,
嫉妒每一个他妈的演员，他们得到了我想要的工作。但我承认。我很嫉妒。你知道吗？但这很好。我们有同样的，我们过去一直谈论它。我记得那是几年前的事了
jealous of every fucking actor out there who gets the job that I'd like. But I admit to it. I'm jealous. You know? But that's good. We had the same, we used to talk about it all the time. I remember this was years ago
当人们开始工作时。正如你所说，大多数时候，我们大多数人没工作，有人会得到一份好工作之类的。我总是和，我们培养了。那些正在工作的人。是的，这是个好孩子。
when people would start to work. And as you say, most of the time, most of us were not working and somebody would get a good job and whatever. And I always stayed friends with, we sort of cultivated. The people who were working. Yeah, it's a good boy.
好孩子。不。他们总能得到晚餐。是的。好吧，它是，但它也像，我们真诚地为彼此加油。任何人，有时会有人进入这个群体，你可以看出是在记分。
Good boy. No. They'll always get dinner. Yeah. Well, it was, but it was also like, we genuinely rooted for each other. And anybody, and sometimes there would be somebody who would come in the group who was, you could tell was keeping score.
不，我经常是。然后你就会把他们剔除。你会把他们剔除。你会觉得，我不是在这儿，我不能和记分的人做朋友。我不能。我同意。每个人都有足够的
No, and that, I just frequently am. And then you would just weed them out. And you'd weed them out. And you'd be like, I'm not here, I can't be friends with people who are keeping score. I just can't. I agree. There's enough for everybody
是的，如果你没有为别人加油的心态，就像你说的你很痛苦，然后去他的，你就完了。是的，我想这就是为什么我想我最近读到一些东西，你说，这让我大声笑了出来，当有人问你，你认为你应该把詹姆斯·邦德的火炬传给谁？你说我不在乎，不关我的事。JB，那是性感的冷漠。别人的他妈的问题。这让我大声笑了出来。所以然后开始做一些工作，开始谋生
Yeah, and and if you're not in the mindset of rooting people on and like you say you're bitter and then fuck then you're fucked Yeah, I thought that's why I thought I just read something recently where you said and I made me laugh out loud when somebody asked you Who do you think you should pass the torch on to for James Bond? You said I don't care Not my business. JB that is sexy indifference. Somebody else's fucking problem. That made me laugh out loud. So then coming up and starting to do some jobs and kind of starting to make a living
没错，如果你没有那种为他人加油的心态，就像你说的，如果你心怀怨恨，那你就完了。我最近刚读到一段话，有人问你觉得谁应该接手詹姆斯·邦德这个角色，你回答说‘我不在乎，那不关我的事’。詹姆斯·邦德，那种性感的冷漠感，那是别人的烂摊子。这让我大笑出声。所以，当你刚起步开始做一些工作，开始谋生的时候
a little bit from it perhaps, were there some other, I'm sure that there were some other jobs that you were doing to kind of starting to make a living a little bit from it, perhaps, were there some other, I'm sure that there were some other jobs that you were doing to kind of pay the bills. I mean, I left home at 16. Yeah. Wow. I went and joined a thing called the National Youth Theatre in London, so I left Liverpool. Liverpool was like, early 80s, as depressed as,
或许从中得到一点，我肯定还有其他工作是你当时为了维持生计而做的，或许，我肯定还有其他工作是你当时为了付账单而做的。我的意思是，我16岁就离家了。是啊。哇。我去了伦敦一个叫国家青年剧院的地方，所以我离开了利物浦。利物浦当时是80年代初，非常萧条，
I mean, so much, it's come up now and the city's doing great, which is just wonderful. But at the time, it was seriously depressed. We had a sort of Trotskyite local council that was hated by Thatcher, who she starved. I mean, it was like the whole thing was just like, employment was like, I can't even, like 35% or 36%, but it was through the roof, whatever it was.
我的意思是，现在情况好多了，城市发展得很好，这真是太棒了。但在当时，它非常萧条。我们有一个被撒切尔夫人憎恨的托洛茨基派地方议会，她对我们进行了经济封锁。我的意思是，整个情况就是，就业率大概只有35%或36%，反正就是高得离谱。
And there was not a lot of job prospects. And I was playing with the idea of joining the roof, whatever it was. And there was not a lot of job prospects. And I was playing with the idea of joining the Navy. I was playing with the idea. You know, I was doing all those things going, well, what do I do? What the fuck do I do? There was nothing to do. And there was a thing called the National Youth Theater,
而且没什么就业前景。我当时在考虑加入海军。我当时在考虑。你知道，我做着所有那些事情，心想，我该怎么办？我到底该怎么办？什么事也做不了。然后有一个叫国家青年剧院的地方，
and it did a summer course, and my mother was a teacher, and it was on the board at her school, and she went this. And I went and auditioned for it in Manchester. I got in, and she sort of kicked me out the door, and she went, you gotta go, you gotta go, go, go, go. And it was partly her ambition because actually she'd got into RADA, which is the kind of top, the top sort of drama school,
它有一个暑期课程，我母亲是一名教师，她是学校董事会的成员，她看到了这个。我去曼彻斯特参加了试镜。我被录取了，她就把我踢出门外，说，你必须去，你必须去，去吧，去吧，去吧。这部分是因为她的抱负，因为实际上她曾被皇家戏剧艺术学院录取，那是当时顶尖的戏剧学校，
certainly of those years, when she was 17, 18 and there was no money to go. There was like, because she didn't, the family just didn't have the money. So she didn't tell me that until about 10 years ago, actually. Oh, wow. Wow. So she, but her ambition for me was just to get going. She must've been absolutely thrilled with your success
当然是在那些年，她17、18岁的时候，但没钱去。因为她没有，家里就是没钱。所以直到大约10年前，她才告诉我这件事。哦，哇。哇。所以她，但她对我的抱负就是让我去闯。她一定对你的成功感到非常激动，
and the arc of your success too, yeah? Yeah, I mean, I think so, yes. Yeah, that's awesome. Awesome, awesome, awesome. And also, and when you say the arc of your success too, yeah? Yeah, I mean, I think so, yes. Yeah, that's awesome. Awesome, awesome, awesome. And also, and when you say the arc too, because you earned it as well. Like, you know, you really. Oh, there she is.
还有你成功的过程，对吧？是啊，我的意思是，我想是的。是啊，那太棒了。太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。而且，当你提到成功的历程时，对吧？是啊，我的意思是，我想是的。是啊，那太棒了。太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。而且，当你提到历程时，因为你也赢得了它。就像，你知道，你真的。哦，她在那儿。
Is that your mom? Look at that. Hey! We already tipped her, by the way, don't. We got this, we got that. Listener, he just had some food delivered. I gotta have a bite of this, I'm sorry. Go ahead, we're doing this. Go on, yeah, yeah.
那是你妈妈吗？看那个。嘿！顺便说一下，我们已经给她小费了，别。我们有这个，我们有那个。听众朋友们，他刚点了外卖。我得吃一口，抱歉。继续，我们在做这个。来吧，是啊，是啊。
Enjoy. So this is a perfect time for me with a long-winded question here so you can choose. Now, let's see, were there weren't any, well, you tell me, were there huge influences or a particular one coming out of England that you were like, if I were to get some traction on this career, that is kind of the path I'd like to be on.
请享用。所以现在是我问一个冗长问题的绝佳时机，你可以选择。现在，让我们看看，有没有，好吧，你告诉我，在你离开英国时，有没有巨大的影响，或者某个特定的影响，让你觉得，如果我要在这个职业生涯中获得一些动力，那就是我想走的道路。
Was it somebody in England or was it somebody in America? Was it always acting, was it directing? The theater thing was the kicker. That was definitely the kind of thing that got me, just, that's what I want to do. And I had some weird thing that I can do that, which is great, but it's just because I was a show off. Right, right. I'm not dressing up, as want to do. And I had some weird thing that I can do that, which is great, but you know, it's just because I was a show off.
是英国的某个人还是美国的某个人？一直都是演戏吗，还是导演？戏剧是关键。那绝对是让我着迷的东西，就是，那是我想要做的。我有一种奇怪的感觉，我可以做到，这很棒，但这只是因为我喜欢炫耀。对，对。我不是在装模作样，而是想做。我有一种奇怪的感觉，我可以做到，这很棒，但这只是因为我喜欢炫耀。
Right, right. I'm not dressing up. So was it like? As I still do. Yeah. So it's like, you know, I mean, so. John Gielgud. Something like that, no?
对，对。我不是在装模作样。所以是像？我依然如此。是啊。所以就像，你知道，我的意思是，所以。约翰·吉尔古德。类似那样，不是吗？
Do you want to try to take me? Yes. I mean, I don't know. Albert Finney. I mean, definitely that generation, Albert Finney's generation, and those guys, I mean, it's just that whole, you know, I suppose they called the angry young men, didn't they?
你想试着带我吗？是的。我的意思是，我不知道。阿尔伯特·芬尼。我的意思是，绝对是那一代人，阿尔伯特·芬尼那一代，还有那些家伙，我的意思是，就是那整个，你知道，我想他们被称为愤怒的青年，不是吗？
Then you worked with Cam Bond, right? I did, yeah, yeah. Oh my God, lucky man. I'm really, I mean just a dream. Yeah. Of a human being and one of the greatest actors ever. Yeah. It was film, really.
然后你和凯姆·邦德合作过，对吧？我合作过，是啊，是啊。天哪，幸运的家伙。我真的，我的意思是简直是梦想。是啊。一个人类，也是有史以来最伟大的演员之一。是啊。那真的是电影。
And that was, we had a little cinema in the town I grew up in, which was, you know, a flea pet, proper, kind of just like a one screen. And all the movies at the time would do the kind of rounds of the country where they'd go to the big screens and things like that. And then by the time we got them, the movie had been out for like a month and a half. And the prints would, I don't remember, the prints were just terrible. But they just, they put films on in rotation. I mean, from Stripes to Quest for Fire, to, you know, I mean, Blade Runner,
那是，我长大的镇上有一个小电影院，你知道，一个跳蚤市场，那种只有一个放映厅的。当时所有的电影都会在全国巡回放映，它们会去大屏幕之类的地方。然后等我们拿到片子时，电影已经上映一个半月了。胶片，我不记得了，胶片简直太糟糕了。但他们只是轮流放映电影。我的意思是，从《条纹》到《火之战》，到，你知道，我的意思是，《银翼杀手》，
I remember seeing in the cinema on my own, with kind of an orange juice and this film came out, I had no idea, it was like blind. I was in there seeing a double bill. It was a Sean Connery space movie called Outland or something. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Does that make sense?
我记得我独自在电影院里，喝着橙汁，这部电影上映了，我完全不知道，就像盲目一样。我在那里看双片连映。那是一部肖恩·康纳利主演的太空电影，叫《九霄云外》之类的。哦，是啊，是啊，是啊。这有意义吗？
Yeah, yeah. That was on, which was pretty great, because it's a cowboy movie in space. And then I kind of went and got a drink and came back and sat down on my own and Blade Runner started. And it was just like, I was like, and that. Was Harrison Ford a bit of a North Star for you?
是啊，是啊。那部电影在放映，非常棒，因为它是一部太空牛仔电影。然后我去喝了杯饮料，回来独自坐下，然后《银翼杀手》开始了。我就像，我当时想，那。哈里森·福特对你来说是北极星吗？
Well, it was the movie itself, it was the whole thing. Yeah. I mean, sure, he is, of course, but the movie itself and the kind of, the fact that movies could look like that, feel like that and do that to you. Right. Was just like the thing.
嗯，是电影本身，是整个东西。是啊。我的意思是，当然，他是，但电影本身以及那种，电影可以看起来那样，感觉那样，并对你产生那种影响的事实。对。就是那件事。
I did, I'd never kind of experienced it. And it felt like a movie that I discovered, that I was, and it was nothing to do with the gun with the wind or the kind of, it's a wonderful life stuff, or the Bond movies even. That was part of, you know. But ultimately kind of intangible though, right? I would imagine there you are sitting in this theater
我以前从未体验过。感觉就像我发现了一部电影，我当时，这与《乱世佳人》或《生活多美好》之类的东西，甚至邦德电影无关。那是其中的一部分，你知道。但最终是无形的，对吧？我想象你坐在那个剧院里
in this small town and you're like, well I'm never going to make it to Hollywood, I'm never going to be up there. That's a million miles away. I was an arrogant little bitch. You actually thought, there is a shot, there's a shot. If I play my cards right, if I get this. I don't know, I mean, it's hindsight, isn't it,
在那个小镇上，你心想，好吧，我永远不会去好莱坞，我永远不会站在那里。那是一百万英里之外。我当时是个傲慢的小混蛋。你真的认为，有机会，有机会。如果我打好牌，如果我得到这个。我不知道，我的意思是，这是事后诸葛亮，不是吗，
that sort of says it, but there was something about. You thought it was possible, which is the key, right? I think so. Why can't, well. But you also got accolades when you were doing theater enough to know that you had something to offer. It was the thing that happened.
那种说法，但确实有某种东西。你认为这是可能的，这是关键，对吧？我想是的。为什么不能，好吧。但你在做戏剧时也获得了足够的赞誉，知道自己有东西可以提供。那是发生的事情。
I kind of left drama school and went and did, I went and did a John G. Avilsdorff movie called The Power of One with Stephen Dorff. Loved Stephen. Scored by Hans Zimmer. I mean, amazingly. Wow. And really kind of weird, I mean, not weird, maybe just a kind of movie of its era. Playing the bad guy and kind of, it was just this sort of event that happened, but it was
我离开戏剧学校后去做了，我去做了一部约翰·G·艾维尔森的电影，叫《权力的力量》，和斯蒂芬·多尔夫一起。很喜欢斯蒂芬。汉斯·季默配乐。我的意思是，令人惊叹。哇。而且真的很奇怪，我的意思是，不奇怪，也许只是那个时代的电影。扮演坏人，我的意思是，这只是发生的某种事件，但它
a movie. And I then came out, I didn't work for a lot, did some theater and then started getting TV roles. Little guest roles and things like that. And suddenly then I got kind of a lead in a TV role and suddenly the money started. It wasn't great but it was like, well, this is like kind of life changing money in the sense I might be able to afford a house soon. Still living in England? Still living in England.
是一部电影。然后我出来后，有一段时间没工作，做了一些戏剧，然后开始获得电视角色。一些小客串角色之类的。突然我得到了一个电视角色的主角，钱开始进来了。虽然不多，但就像，好吧，这是一种改变生活的钱，意味着我可能很快就能买得起房子了。还在英国住吗？还在英国住。
I'd gone to LA after the Power of One. And it was like 1991 and arriving here. Kind of and kind of not because I was so green and naive. I landed in this town, I didn't have a driver's license, and I didn't have a credit card. me into the Universal Sheraton, which I realize now is an island. You need a car to get off it. I kind of went to the front desk and they said, credit card. They were looking at me like I had to embarrassly call up Warner Brothers and get them to put
我在《权力的力量》之后去了洛杉矶。那是1991年，刚到这里。有点，又有点不是，因为我太天真了。我降落在那个镇上，没有驾照，也没有信用卡。把我带到环球喜来登酒店，我现在意识到那是一个孤岛。你需要一辆车才能离开它。我走到前台，他们说，信用卡。他们看着我，就像我不得不尴尬地打电话给华纳兄弟，让他们把
some money down on the desk and do all these things. And then John D. Alvison very nicely was sort of pushing me slightly because he's like, you kid, this kid's got it, this kid's got it, he was pushing me slightly. So I went up for auditions and in the movie I was playing a Nazi kind of South African bad guy. And I was going up for Nazi South African bad guys. I mean that was it. I went up for like five auditions and it was all for,
一些钱放在桌子上，做所有这些事情。然后约翰·D·艾维尔森非常好心地在推我，因为他觉得，这孩子有天赋，这孩子有天赋，他在推我。所以我去参加试镜，在电影里我扮演一个纳粹式的南非坏人。我去参加纳粹南非坏人的试镜。我的意思是就是那样。我参加了大约五次试镜，全都是为了，
you know, it was all for the Nazis. And I just was like, I was just like, yeah, I mean, I've got a bit more range than this, I think. And there was a kind of, suddenly there was an offer on the table from a manager, and why don't you stay and we get you accommodation, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I kind of went on and I did these five auditions and I went, whoa, no, this is going to go really wrong. And I don't know what it was, it was just like,
你知道，全都是为了纳粹。我当时就想，我当时就想，是啊，我的意思是，我觉得我的戏路比这宽一点。突然有一个经纪人给出了报价，为什么你不留下来，我们给你安排住宿，等等等等。我继续做了这五次试镜，然后我想，哇，不，这会变得非常糟糕。我不知道那是什么，只是觉得，
where these thoughts came from, I have no idea. But they were just like, this is not the career I want. So I went home. Back to England, back to theater. Back to England, well, sort of back to thinking, well, I've got a bit of money in my pocket, I've got a bit of money now, so it's okay. But then suddenly I started getting bigger roles
这些想法从哪儿来的，我不知道。但它们就像，这不是我想要的职业生涯。所以我回家了。回到英国，回到戏剧。回到英国，好吧，算是回到思考，好吧，我口袋里有点钱，我现在有点钱了，所以没关系。但突然我开始获得更大的角色
in television, and I realized that was a mistake. Because I looked at these bit of money now, so it's okay. But then suddenly I started getting bigger roles in television and I realized that was a mistake because I looked at these television stars at home and God bless them, they're earning money and they've got the house in Portugal and they're thinking, yeah, they're set, set, it's great. I want to make movies, I want to make movies. Good for you. And the British movie industry didn't exist.
在电视里，我意识到那是个错误。因为我看着这些电视明星在家里，上帝保佑他们，他们赚着钱，在葡萄牙有房子，他们心想，是啊，他们安顿下来了，安顿下来了，这很棒。我想拍电影，我想拍电影。为你高兴。而英国电影业并不存在。
Right, it just didn't. I mean, there were amazing movies coming out. You think about, you know, like... Room with a view. I mean, room with a view, but I'm talking kind of like, I mean, no one was ever going to cast me in. Because I wasn't a floppy-fringed kind of posh boy. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, that's what I mean.
对，它就是不存在。我的意思是，有很棒的电影出来。你想到，你知道，比如……《看得见风景的房间》。我的意思是，《看得见风景的房间》，但我说的是那种，我的意思是，没人会选我。因为我不是那种留着刘海的势利小男孩。是啊，是啊，是啊。好吧，这就是我的意思。
Like the sort of the... So there was lots of brilliant directors, like, you know, my beautiful Laundrette, and the sort of the... So there was lots of brilliant directors like, you know, my beautiful Laundrette and things like that were going on. But that was a kind of, you know, you had to know the director and things and I sort of plugged away at it until someone gave me a break. But what was the shift in that in the British film? For me? I mean, yeah.
就像那种……所以有很多出色的导演，比如，你知道，《我的美丽洗衣店》，那种……所以有很多出色的导演，比如，你知道，《我的美丽洗衣店》之类的东西正在进行。但那是一种，你知道，你必须认识导演之类的，我坚持不懈，直到有人给了我一个机会。但英国电影发生了什么转变？对我来说？我的意思是，是啊。
I did a film called Love is a Devil. And that was, that got some traction for you? It's as these things do. Like I say this to young actors, they talk about when the break comes, and I'm going to do this thing. It's like believing producers say, this is going to be good for you,
我拍了一部叫《爱是魔鬼》的电影。那部电影，那为你获得了一些关注？就像这些事情一样。就像我告诉年轻演员的那样，他们谈论机会什么时候来，我要做这件事。这就像相信制片人说，这对你有好处，
this is going to be good for you, this. It doesn't happen like that in the industry. It's tectonic. It rolls around. You get the break, someone comes and sees you in something, or sees you in something, a year later they might go, let's tectonic, it's like it rolls around. You get the break, like someone comes and sees you in something or sees you in something, a year later they might go, let's get that guy.
这对你有好处，这。在行业里不是那样发生的。它是构造性的。它会轮转。你得到了机会，有人来看你演戏，或者在某处看到你，一年后他们可能会说，让我们构造性的，就像它会轮转。你得到了机会，就像有人来看你演戏或者在某处看到你，一年后他们可能会说，让我们找那个家伙。
And you can't rush these things. So I did things and I just kept on going and eventually sort of something, momentum started happening and then I don't know what kind of went down. I did a TV series and then wrote a petition, like you know, Sam cast me and wrote a petition, and then Munich. Did you know Sam Mendes before that?
你不能催促这些事情。所以我做了这些事，我只是继续前进，最终某种动力开始产生，然后我不知道发生了什么。我拍了一部电视剧，然后写了一份请愿书，就像你知道，萨姆选了我，写了一份请愿书，然后是《慕尼黑》。在那之前你认识萨姆·门德斯吗？
To say hello to. Yeah, so then it was, so then when you audition, I'd imagine that was an audition, not an offer. It was a friendly face in the audition room. I blew it. You did? No. Not a good audition.
打过招呼。是啊，所以当，所以当你试镜时，我想那是一次试镜，而不是一个报价。试镜室里有一张熟悉的面孔。我搞砸了。你搞砸了？不。不是一次好的试镜。
Come on. No. Did you apologize audition. Come on. No. Did you apologize after your audition? As you're leaving, I'm so sorry you had to see that. Good luck with the project. That's my go-to. It works.
得了吧。不。你在试镜后道歉了吗？当你离开时，我很抱歉你不得不看到那个。祝项目好运。那是我的惯用语。它有效。
Sometimes it works. Sometimes it works, yeah. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. For some reason, I didn't. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. For some reason, I didn't. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent.
有时它有效。有时它有效，是啊。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。出于某种原因，我没有。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。出于某种原因，我没有。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。
I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent, but for some reason I didn't. For the audition, I kind of, I really couldn't. He hadn't offered it to me, but he sort of said to me, we really want you to play the part. I thought, well, that's an offer.
我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音。我本应该学会这种芝加哥口音，但出于某种原因我没有。对于试镜，我有点，我真的做不到。他没有给我报价，但他对我说了，我们真的想让你演这个角色。我想，好吧，那是一个报价。
And he said, now you've got to fly out to Chicago and audition. I was like, really? Yeah. So I didn't really do enough work on the part. I kind of went, did this terrible reading, and he sort of went, stop, stop, you've got the job. Oh, I don't want to. I sort of, I kind of, you know,
他说，现在你得飞到芝加哥去试镜。我当时想，真的吗？是啊。所以我没有在角色上下足够的功夫。我去了，做了这次糟糕的朗读，他有点说，停，停，你得到这份工作了。哦，我不想。我有点，我有点，你知道，
batted him down with terrible acting. It's a ploy. All right, so then you're on set, and you're working with Tom Hanks and Paul Newman and being directed by Mr. Mendez. Tom Hanks and Paul Newman and being directed by Mr. Mendez, did you get winded or was it just sort of like, yeah, this is kind of, it's about time and off we go. And this is what I've been trying to do.
用糟糕的演技把他打发了。这是一种策略。好吧，所以你在片场，你和汤姆·汉克斯、保罗·纽曼一起工作，并由门德斯先生执导。汤姆·汉克斯和保罗·纽曼，并由门德斯先生执导，你感到气喘吁吁，还是觉得，是啊，这有点，是时候了，我们走吧。这就是我一直试图做的。
I've been trying to avoid the other stuff and now I've landed in the sort of the lane I want to be in a little bit. I mean. Convo? I mean, I would, I kind of, yeah. I mean, I just felt, I felt like terrified and all of those things, but like, you're here now.
我一直试图避免其他事情，现在我降落在我想要进入的轨道上了。我的意思是。谈话？我的意思是，我会，我有点，是啊。我的意思是，我只是感到，我感到害怕以及所有那些事情，但就像，你现在在这里了。
Right. You better fucking. You better deliver. You better deliver. And did you find that you had a gear that you didn't know that could kind of boost you up and so you didn't have a panic attack and you held your own, yes?
对。你最好该死的。你最好表现出来。你最好表现出来。你有没有发现你有一种你不知道的档位可以提升你，所以你没有恐慌发作，你坚持住了，是吗？
I mean, I suppose what it was, what really calmed me when it boils down to it, you're on set with one of the greatest living actors of all time. And Paul Newman. And Paul Newman. Both of them, but very, very, very different actors. But Paul Newman, who I've idolized, and watching him work, you realize, oh god, he's an actor. And it's just
我的意思是，我想那是，真正让我冷静下来的是，归根结底，你和有史以来最伟大的在世演员之一在片场。还有保罗·纽曼。还有保罗·纽曼。他们两个，但非常，非常，非常不同的演员。但保罗·纽曼，我崇拜他，看着他工作，你意识到，哦天哪，他是个演员。这只是
that sort of like that in itself was like, he's, I can't talk to him about, he wanted to talk to me about racing cars. I was like, going four wheels? I mean, you know, because like, he's like talking about like, I mean, I just, why the indie series was so much better than the Grand Prix series? I was like, yeah. And it was like, I couldn't. But when it came down to it and watching and working with him,
那种本身就像是，他，我不能和他谈论，他想和我谈论赛车。我当时想，四个轮子？我的意思是，你知道，因为他就像在谈论，我的意思是，我只是，为什么印地系列赛比大奖赛系列赛好得多？我当时想，是啊。就像，我不能。但当它归结为看着他并与他一起工作时，
I had a language that I could speak to him in, because I'm an actor, he's an actor, and he really is, you know. And he'd struggle and he'd really be kind of trying to find it and things like that, just be like, oh wow, great, that's what I do. Oh good, yeah. And that kind of just, so I can get, you know, I mean. He forgets a line too sometimes. Right, yeah.
我有一种可以和他交流的语言，因为我是演员，他是演员，他确实是，你知道。他会挣扎，他会真的试图找到它之类的，就像，哦哇，太棒了，这就是我做的。哦好，是啊。那种只是，所以我可以得到，你知道，我的意思是。他有时也会忘词。对，是啊。
Oh that's great. That's really cool. Yeah, that's really interesting, that idea of being with Paul Newman and watching him kind of find it in the scene. That is the opposite of making you nervous, it actually calms you because you see him as human. Yeah, you must have had a complete, like your nerves must have been absolutely settled in that moment.
哦，那太棒了。那真的很酷。是啊，那真的很有趣，那种和保罗·纽曼在一起，看着他在场景中找到感觉的想法。那与让你紧张相反，它实际上让你冷静，因为你看到他是一个人。是啊，在那一刻你的神经一定完全平静下来了。
I was like, we can do this, we can make this happen, we're playing. Suddenly we're like, we're here to play, great, I know how to play. Fascinating. One time I was doing the bucket list with Jack Nicholson and Morgan Freeman. I was in a scene with Jack Nicholson. Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you. And he turns to me and he goes, during rehearsal he goes, do you know what you mean when you say that line?
我当时想，我们可以做到，我们可以让它发生，我们在玩。突然我们就像，我们在这里玩，太棒了，我知道怎么玩。迷人。有一次我和杰克·尼科尔森和摩根·弗里曼拍《遗愿清单》。我和杰克·尼科尔森有一场戏。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。他转向我，他说，在排练期间他说，你知道你说那句台词是什么意思吗？
I go, yeah, do you? Ha! Like, what? Nice dick. I had to say that. You're a dick. Yeah, in your head. I had to say that to relax myself because I couldn't believe I was in a movie with Jack Nicholson. We'll be right back.
我说，是啊，你知道吗？哈！就像，什么？好个混蛋。我不得不那样说。你是个混蛋。是啊，在你的脑子里。我不得不那样说来放松自己，因为我不敢相信我在和杰克·尼科尔森拍电影。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. Now Daniel, when you were very quickly after that, sort of vaulted into much more of a leadership position on the jobs that followed, did you take that experience with you as a leader and see the younger actors, or the actors with lesser parts, get a little sort of nervous?
现在回到节目。现在丹尼尔，在那之后很快，你被提升到后续工作中更多的领导地位，你是否把那种经验作为领导者带在身上，看到年轻演员，或者戏份较少的演员，变得有点紧张？
And did you lend some of that comfort to them by, not intentionally forgetting a line, but did you lend some of that comfort to them by, not intentionally forgetting a line, but did you take some of those leadership lessons? By being completely shit. Yeah. It really just settles everybody's nerves. Oh my God. Fake a panic attack.
你是否通过，不是故意忘词，而是通过，你是否通过，不是故意忘词，而是通过，你是否吸取了一些领导经验？通过表现得完全糟糕。是啊。这真的让每个人的神经都平静下来了。天哪。假装恐慌发作。
That's how he's going to do it. I don't know, I mean, I feel like part of my job is to, you know, you're on set. I love being around actors. I love being, you know, it's fun. It's a lot of fun. If you have somebody who is there for a bit, short day, I have a thing. It's like my favorite movies, it's those small parts that zip out, that make the movie sometimes. It's like you encourage them to be the best they can because it's like, you know, it's like, Smallest Cogs, all of that shit.
这就是他要做的。我不知道，我的意思是，我觉得我的工作一部分是，你知道，你在片场。我喜欢和演员在一起。我喜欢，你知道，这很有趣。这很有趣。如果你有某个人在那里待一会儿，短的一天，我有一个习惯。就像我最喜欢的电影，是那些跳出来的小角色，有时成就了电影。就像你鼓励他们成为最好的自己，因为就像，你知道，就像，最小的齿轮，所有那些狗屁。
Sure, there's no small parts, there's small actors. Exactly. Yeah. What about siblings? Do you have siblings? I have a half brother, an sister, an older sister. And different, completely different career path than you? Completely different, yeah.
当然，没有小角色，只有小演员。正是。是啊。兄弟姐妹呢？你有兄弟姐妹吗？我有一个同父异母的兄弟，一个姐妹，一个姐姐。和你的职业道路完全不同？完全不同，是啊。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I'm kind of the only actor in the family. And I want to talk about eggs that you just ate. Do you always watch what you eat when you're on doing these junkets? Like, you didn't want to touch the potatoes. I was just watching you garble those eggs.
是啊，是啊，是啊。是啊，是啊。我的意思是，我是家里唯一的演员。我想谈谈你刚吃的鸡蛋。你在做这些宣传活动时总是注意饮食吗？就像，你不想碰土豆。我刚才看着你狼吞虎咽地吃那些鸡蛋。
Sean knows, can he send a guy over to pick up the potatoes? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's somebody at your door right now, Daniel, if you don't mind, just real quick. Just slide the potatoes under the door. No, are you always like that,
肖恩知道，他能派个人过来拿走土豆吗？是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。丹尼尔，如果你不介意的话，现在你门口有人，就一会儿。把土豆从门下塞进来就行。不，你总是那样吗，
or do you go off the rails sometimes? I mean, I do, I used to swing on Bond. I'll finish this. Yeah, right, here we go. Unless that's not a good word. to swing on Bond. That's not a good word. On Bond, because of the intensity, I would then spend the next three, four months being drunk and eating.
还是你有时会失控？我的意思是，我做过，我过去在邦德电影上摇摆不定。我会完成这个。是啊，对，我们开始吧。除非那不是个好词。在邦德电影上摇摆不定。那不是个好词。在邦德电影上，因为强度，我接下来会花三、四个月的时间喝醉和吃东西。
That's not good for you. I stopped doing that and said, okay, let's maintain my fitness. How about that? Yeah, yeah, yeah. You my fitness, how about that? And I thought, thank you. It gets so hard after 50, yeah? I mean, we're all in our 50s. It's so depressing. It's so depressing.
这对你不好。我停止那样做，说，好吧，让我们保持健康。那样怎么样？是啊，是啊，是啊。你我的健康，那样怎么样？我想，谢谢。50岁以后变得太难了，是吧？我的意思是，我们都50多岁了。太令人沮丧了。太令人沮丧了。
I remember before I found my mom up a few years ago and going, oh, my fingers are aching, and just, welcome to my world. I mean, it's just that, it's just that's what it is. I've got all these little hotspots on my hands now that like, it hurts between this finger and this finger and right at the base of the thumb there, it's like, what's going on?
我记得几年前我找到我妈妈，说，哦，我的手指在疼，欢迎来到我的世界。我的意思是，这就是，这就是它的本质。我现在手上有很多小热点，就像，这根手指和那根手指之间疼，就在拇指根部那里，就像，发生了什么？
I had this treatment the other day where they gave me this infrared thing where they kind of map your body infrared and my hands were on fire and they were like, we're going, oh, what's wrong? And I'm like, I don't know what is wrong. It's like, it hurts. I'm not 20.
前几天我做了这个治疗，他们给了我这个红外线东西，他们用红外线映射你的身体，我的手着火了，他们就像，我们正在，哦，怎么了？我就像，我不知道怎么了。就像，它疼。我不是20岁了。
Wait a second, wait, Sean, you did a similar, no, JB, you did a math thing. I did the full body scan, yeah. Full body scan. And it was, thank God, it was all good, but it's kind of cool that they can do that now. What did they find in the place where the human heart normally is?
等一下，等一下，肖恩，你做了一个类似的，不，JB，你做了一个数学测试。我做了全身扫描，是啊。全身扫描。谢天谢地，一切都好，但他们现在能做到这一点真的很酷。他们在人类心脏通常所在的地方发现了什么？
Not much. There was like, a little movie camera rolling in there. Just a bunch of loose nuts and bolts. Wait, Daniel, also just meeting you for the first time, I sense that your brain works really, really fast. Like you're hyper intelligent and you kind of have to when you're doing all the things that you do. What do you do to slow it?
没多少。就像，里面有一个小电影摄像机在转动。只是一堆松动的螺母和螺栓。等等，丹尼尔，第一次见到你，我感觉到你的大脑工作得非常非常快。就像你超级聪明，当你做所有你做的事情时，你不得不这样。你做什么来减慢它？
I'm not getting that, Sean. Really? I do, I get that you're like, your brain works really, really fast. Like you're eating the eggs and you're finishing the story and then you're going like, you ever see? He's not a dummy, okay?
我没听懂，肖恩。真的吗？我懂，我懂你就像，你的大脑工作得非常非常快。就像你在吃鸡蛋，你在讲完故事，然后你就像，你见过吗？他不是个傻瓜，好吗？
I know that's what I'm saying. Sean's so shocked. How is he chewing and walking at the same time? By the way, this is coming from a guy who spends a Monday afternoon, mid-afternoon watching videos of Childbirth. He's a childbirth. So it's not like he doesn't have a lot going on.
我知道这就是我要说的。肖恩太震惊了。他怎么能一边咀嚼一边走路？顺便说一下，这来自一个周一下午，下午中期看分娩视频的家伙。他是个分娩。所以这并不是说他没有很多事情要做。
Yeah, it's gonna feel like doesn't have a lot going on. Yeah, it's going to feel like a compliment's coming, but the curve is... Yeah, the bar could be fucking lower. No, it is a big compliment because you have to think, you constantly have to think fast of what you do. You're like, the camera's there, my line's here, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
是啊，这会感觉不像有很多事情要做。是啊，这会感觉像是一个恭维，但曲线是……是啊，门槛可能会低得该死。不，这是一个很大的恭维，因为你必须思考，你必须不断地快速思考你所做的事情。你就像，摄像机在那里，我的台词在这里，等等等等等等，
and you have kids and you have the thing. So your mind's always going, what do you do to calm down? I don't know. I mean, it's just being at home. And I like to, I really, really, really don't play tennis. I'm so terrible. But if I can convince, you know, like a tennis pro or someone to hit a ball with me,
你有孩子，你有那件事。所以你的大脑总是转个不停，你做什么来冷静下来？我不知道。我的意思是，只是待在家里。我喜欢，我真的，真的，真的不打网球。我太糟糕了。但如果我能说服，你知道，比如网球职业选手或某人和我打球，
I'll do that for two, three hours at a time. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's good. I just kind of like, and you know. No golf for you? Yeah, whatever, what's the, ruin's a good walk, what are you talking about? Yeah, but it is a nice walk.
我会一次做两、三个小时。是啊，是啊，是啊。那很好。我只是有点喜欢，而且你知道。你不打高尔夫？是啊，随便，什么是，毁掉是一次好的散步，你在说什么？是啊，但那是一次不错的散步。
It is a great, great walk. Now what about, now you've been to all these incredible, in all the films you've done, all these incredible locations around the world, is there a spot that calms you more than any, a favorite spot? I think if I'm going to really relax, the sea is like the place I want to be, because it's like, I just want the salt water,
那是一次很棒，很棒的散步。现在关于，现在你去过所有这些令人难以置信的地方，在你拍的所有电影中，世界各地所有这些令人难以置信的地点，有没有一个地方比任何地方都让你平静，一个最喜欢的地方？我想如果我真的要放松，大海是我想要去的地方，因为就像，我只是想要盐水，
and I want the sun, and my body kind of, again with the aches and the pains. You're not a boat guy though, are you? Are you a guy that? Not really, they're kind of, that's a lot of hard work. Yeah. I have like two fan stuff, can we just get it out of the way?
我想要阳光，我的身体有点，又是那些疼痛。你不是个船夫，对吧？你是那种？不是真的，它们有点，那是很多艰苦的工作。是啊。我有两个粉丝的东西，我们可以把它解决掉吗？
Yeah, of course, man. Because Scotty, my husband and I watched all your films like a billion times. The Javier Bardem and you probably have the greatest hero villain chemistry of all time, like just incredible what Do you tell Tracy what that's for Tracy's that's from? Oh my god. That's from my full skyfall. Thanks And do you a talent you have to sing Adele whenever say the net? No, you don't go ahead with the question
是啊，当然，伙计。因为斯科蒂，我和我丈夫看了你所有的电影大概十亿次。哈维尔·巴登和你可能拥有有史以来最伟大的英雄反派化学反应，就像简直不可思议，你告诉特雷西那是为了什么，特雷西那是来自？天哪。那是来自我的《天幕杀机》。谢谢，你有没有天赋在任何时候唱阿黛尔？不，你没有，继续问问题
No you don't. Go ahead with the question. No, the... No, I just... It's just a comment, not a question. It's just a comment. Like, that was incredible. And do you guys still... Do you still keep in touch with Javier? I do. I see. I talk to him occasionally and yes, I love him to death. He's just... He's just like... He's a glorious human being. So good. And then the other thing was, and you can think about it while we talk about other stuff,
不，你没有。继续问问题。不，那个……不，我只是……这只是一个评论，不是一个问题。这只是一个评论。就像，那太不可思议了。你们还……你们还和哈维尔保持联系吗？我保持。我见。我偶尔和他谈话，是的，我爱死他了。他只是……他只是像……他是一个光荣的人类。太好了。然后另一件事是，你可以在我们谈论其他事情时考虑一下，
unless you have to go, is a great theater story. I was asked, like, people with theater while we talk about other stuff, unless you have to go, is a great theater story. I always ask people with theater stories, like scenes falling, like people throwing up on stage, like anything like that. I've done all that, I've done all that. Really? Yeah, I've done all that. Really?
除非你必须走，是一个伟大的戏剧故事。我被问到，就像，人们在谈论戏剧时，除非你必须走，是一个伟大的戏剧故事。我总是问有戏剧故事的人，就像场景倒塌，就像人们在舞台上呕吐，就像任何类似的事情。我做过所有那些，我做过所有那些。真的吗？是啊，我做过所有那些。真的吗？
You name it. The amount of theater you've done is just stunning. I've done it, it's happened on stage. What do you think was the worst thing that happened where you were like fucked up a performance or like an audience member? I haven't, I mean, I've been at the theater when it was actually, Leo Schreiber was doing,
你说得出来。你做过的戏剧数量简直令人震惊。我做过，它在舞台上发生过。你认为发生的最糟糕的事情是什么，让你觉得搞砸了表演，或者像观众？我没有，我的意思是，我在剧院里，当时实际上，列夫·施赖伯正在做，
what are they doing, a few from the bridge, but where literally someone had a thing, an attack, and Leo actually got to say, is there a doctor in the house? I mean, he was like, wow, it's like, and there was, and the guy was fine, and it was all good. I was kind of like, yeah, they stopped the show. So the amount of work that goes into doing theater
他们在做什么，桥头眺望，但字面上有人有事情，发作，列夫实际上不得不说，屋子里有医生吗？我的意思是，他就像，哇，就像，而且有，那个人没事，一切都好。我当时有点像，是啊，他们停止了演出。所以投入到做戏剧的工作量
at the level that you've done and that Sean just did, is it, I'm sure you can't compare that to the kind of rigor it takes to get through a huge, huge film, but is it somewhat comparable? And if so, which do you prefer as far as what takes most out of you? I think a movie takes the most out of you because I think it's a seven day a week job. It's not that you can't get, there's no day off really because there's always something to do on whatever.
在你做过的水平上，以及肖恩刚才做的，是，我肯定你不能把它与完成一部巨大、巨大电影所需的严谨性相提并论，但它有可比性吗？如果是这样，你更喜欢哪一个，因为什么最消耗你？我认为电影最消耗你，因为我认为这是一份每周七天的工作。并不是说你不能得到，没有休息日，因为总是有事情要做，无论什么。
Either you're doing a five day a week or you're doing a six day a week. You're either rehearsing something or you're studying something. So the intensity of that is like, there's nothing. And a play once it's up and running gets its own kind of momentum. I mean, if it's an emotionally difficult play, then obviously it's kind of like it gets, you know, but you sort of tend to be able to kind of like spend the day not thinking about it. And then go and do it.
要么你每周做五天，要么你每周做六天。你要么在排练某事，要么在学习某事。所以那种强度，就像，什么都没有。而一部戏一旦开始运行，它就有自己的动力。我的意思是，如果这是一部情感上困难的戏，那么显然它有点像它变得，你知道，但你倾向于能够花一天时间不去想它。然后去演它。
Do you see yourself staying on screen until you're old and gray and in the ground? Or would you like to sort of throttle back and just have the last section of your life whenever that starts, just on theater. Because that's something that I kind of fantasize about, is just like moving to New York and becoming a theater actor and just like riding my bike to the theater.
你看到自己留在屏幕上直到你老了、灰白了、入土了吗？还是你想稍微减速，让你的生命最后一部分，无论什么时候开始，只在戏剧上？因为那是我有点幻想的事情，就是搬到纽约，成为一名戏剧演员，就像骑自行车去剧院。
It's very attractive. I mean, I don't know, it depends how big the bills are, isn't it, right? Yeah, that's true. Well, back to the TV stars. Yeah, exactly, I mean, right, so, I don't know. I did work with Gilgud. I worked with Gilgud on two jobs.
这非常有吸引力。我的意思是，我不知道，这取决于账单有多大，不是吗，对吧？是啊，那是真的。好吧，回到电视明星。是啊，正是，我的意思是，对，所以，我不知道。我和吉尔古德合作过。我和吉尔古德在两份工作上合作过。
He was actually in The Power of One. I played the headmaster at this school, and I did have a scene with him, but I met him. I met him around the back of the set, because I'd gone around to have a cigarette back in the day when I smoked. And there he was, smoking. And he kind of went, oh, don't tell anybody
他实际上在《权力的力量》里。我扮演这所学校的校长，我确实和他有一场戏，但我见过他。我在片场后面见过他，因为我过去抽烟的时候去抽烟。他就在那里，抽烟。他有点说，哦，别告诉任何人
I'm not supposed to be smoking. And I was like, I thought we had a cigarette together and had a chat, which was like, you know. And then I did Elizabeth about 10 years later, and he must have been well into his 90s by then. Wow. And it was kind of, why is he working? Because his boyfriend liked diamonds.
我不应该抽烟。我当时想，我想我们一起抽了根烟，聊了聊天，就像，你知道。然后大约10年后我拍了《伊丽莎白》，那时他一定已经90多岁了。哇。而且有点，他为什么要工作？因为他的男朋友喜欢钻石。
I mean, it was kind of like he was that, that was the response, you know, it was that. And he was wheeled in, and I kind of thought I had the scene with him, just to sort of like, he was playing the pope, and I was playing this Jesuit mass murderer. Easy role. I just sort of, I kind of went to take care of him.
我的意思是，他就是那样，那是回应，你知道，就是那样。他被推了进来，我有点以为我和他有那场戏，只是为了，就像，他扮演教皇，我扮演这个耶稣会的大规模杀人犯。容易的角色。我只是有点，我有点去照顾他。
My instinct was to sort of tell him, how are you, you probably don't remember, we had a cigarette together, you know, and of course he didn't remember. But he was like, I could see the age, and he was like, oh my God, wow, he's really kind of, is he going to be able to remember his lines? The board went on, bang.
我的本能是告诉他，你好吗，你可能不记得了，我们一起抽过烟，你知道，当然他不记得了。但他就像，我能看到年龄，他就像，哦天哪，哇，他真的有点，他能记住他的台词吗？板子响了，砰。
Just showed up. The back went up when he was just like, and he did the scene like, it was like, oh man, blew everybody away, and then kind of went back, and it was like, wow, that's, that's, and I kind of was like, that's amazing, but I was also kind of like, I don't know if you've ever ridden a horse in a movie. They have to retire movie horses
只是出现了。当他就像，他演那场戏就像，就像，哦伙计，让每个人都惊呆了，然后有点回去，就像，哇，那是，那是，我有点像，那太神奇了，但我也有点像，我不知道你是否曾经在电影里骑过马。他们必须让电影马退休
because they learn the board. They learn. When the sleigh comes in and they hit it whack, it's time to go. Yeah, so I've sat on horses that are kind of like, wait a minute, you know, because I don't ride very well, I was sticking on that nag, you know,
因为它们学会了板子。它们学会了。当雪橇进来，他们打它砰，是时候走了。是啊，所以我坐过那种马，有点像，等一下，你知道，因为我骑得不太好，我坚持在那匹劣马上，你知道，
it's because it's like, and they're kind of like there, and the dog's trying to pull its head up, trying to look cool, but it's just like, it's because it's like, and they're kind of like there, and the dance mat's trying to pull its head up, trying to look cool, but it's just like, look, it's like it's going to die. And they put the board on it, and it's like, it's, oh my God, Jesus Christ! And they can't, they have to retire these horses. And I thought, oh my God, you're a film horse.
是因为它就像，它们有点在那里，狗试图把头抬起来，试图看起来很酷，但它只是因为就像，它们有点在那里，舞蹈垫试图把头抬起来，试图看起来很酷，但它只是因为就像，看，它就像它要死了。他们把板子放在它身上，它就像，它，哦天哪，耶稣基督！他们不能，他们必须让这些马退休。我想，哦天哪，你是一匹电影马。
That's kind of what, do I want to turn into a film horse? When that board goes on, oh yeah, here we are, here we are. But at the same time, I mean, maybe there's a little bit of wisdom in staying active in that way is part of the reason that he was able to be alive in his 90s. I mean, maybe do a crossword, I don't know. Yeah, because otherwise he's in Portugal, right? No, totally, totally, I get it. I mean, going back to that hysteria in the school play,
这就是，我想变成一匹电影马吗？当那块板子放上去时，哦是啊，我们在这儿，我们在这儿。但与此同时，我的意思是，也许以那种方式保持活跃有一点智慧，是他能够活到90多岁的部分原因。我的意思是，也许做个填字游戏，我不知道。是啊，因为否则他在葡萄牙，对吧？不，完全，完全，我明白了。我的意思是，回到学校戏剧里的那种歇斯底里，
that thing, that drug, that thing that gets you in the... See how I brought it back there? It's really good. You know, I like it. I like it. I kind of wanted to get back, I'm glad you mentioned that, because I kind of wanted to go back to that moment
那件事，那种毒品，那种让你进入……看我怎么把它带回来的？这真的很好。你知道，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我有点想回到，我很高兴你提到那个，因为我有点想回到那一刻
you're in the theater, and go all the way back to that moment you're in the theater, you're watching Blade Runner, because it really made me think about, I was going to bring this up before, and I was going to ask you guys, what is that thing? What was that sort of seminal moment in your life? What was the film, the book that you read,
你在剧院里，一直回到那一刻你在剧院里，你在看《银翼杀手》，因为它真的让我思考，我本来要在之前提出来，我要问你们，那是什么东西？你生命中那个开创性的时刻是什么？那部电影，你读过的那本书，
and do you go back and still, because I have found now that I'm in my 50s, I'm now re-looking for moments like that where I get inspired, I'm reading a book right now. That's called Midlife Crisis. It is a midlife crisis, believe me. I should be wearing a fucking hat the last 10 years that said ask me about my midlife crisis. It is a midlife crisis. Believe me, I should be wearing a fucking hat the last 10 years that said,
你会回头看吗？因为我发现现在我五十多岁了，我正在重新寻找那些能让我获得灵感的时刻。我最近正在读一本书，叫《中年危机》。相信我，这确实是中年危机。过去十年里，我真该戴顶帽子，上面写着“问我关于中年危机的事”。这确实是中年危机。相信我，过去十年里，我真该戴顶帽子，上面写着，
ask me about my midlife crisis. Yeah. But, and yes, I had a Porsche, obviously, and I've had, but all of that, do, you know, do you guys, have you guys had those moments? Do you remember being young in a book or a film or something?
“问我关于中年危机的事”。是的。但是，还有，是的，我当然有一辆保时捷，我也拥有过……但所有这些，你们呢？你们有过这样的时刻吗？还记得年轻时看过的某本书或某部电影吗？
Yes. You went like. Mine is 11 years old. I was 11 years old. My brother took me for my 11th birthday. Have you guys had those moments? Do you remember being young in a book or a film or something? You went like... Mine is 11 years old. I was 11 years old. My brother took me for my 11th birthday. My brother, Kevin, took me to go see E.T. And I was 11 years old. And everybody in the theater was crying,
是的。你当时的感觉就像……我那时11岁。我11岁的时候，我哥哥带我去过我的11岁生日。你们有过这样的时刻吗？还记得年轻时看过的某本书或某部电影吗？你当时的感觉就像……我那时11岁。我11岁的时候，我哥哥带我去过我的11岁生日。我哥哥凯文带我去看《E.T.外星人》。那时我11岁。电影院里的每个人都在哭，
as they were at the end. And I said to my brother, I said I'd give anything to be him. And my brother thought, like the fantasy, like, oh, Elliot, to have a friend like E.T. And I go, no, I'd give anything to be Henry Thomas my brother thought, the fantasy, like, oh, Elliot to have a friend like E.T. and I go, no, I'd give anything to be Henry Thomas. Who played Elliot.
就像电影结尾时那样。我对哥哥说，我说我愿意付出一切成为他。我哥哥以为，就像那种幻想，哦，艾略特，能有E.T.这样的朋友。我说，不，我愿意付出一切成为亨利·托马斯。我哥哥以为，就像那种幻想，哦，艾略特，能有E.T.这样的朋友。我说，不，我愿意付出一切成为亨利·托马斯。就是扮演艾略特的那个演员。
And my brother's like, the actor? And I was like, yeah, to make people feel that? That would be amazing. JB, anything, do you remember a moment you were inspired by something? Matthew Broderick to Brighton Beach Memoirs on Broadway. I think I was like 15 or something. And I could have gone, there was like,
我哥哥问，那个演员？我说，是的，能让人们有那种感觉？那太棒了。JB，有什么吗？你还记得被什么东西激励的时刻吗？马修·布罗德里克在百老汇演的《布莱顿海滩回忆录》。我想我当时大概15岁左右。我当时可能……
I was a fork in the road. I could have stopped doing what I was doing. But I saw him do that and I just had such a good time. And I was like, oh, I want to do that. Keep doing that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. For me, it wasn't even seeing, for me it was, I was 17, I remember this so clearly,
我当时站在人生的十字路口。我本可以停止做我正在做的事。但我看到他那样表演，我度过了一段非常美好的时光。我当时想，哦，我想做那个。继续做那个。是的，是的，是的。对我来说，甚至不是看到什么，对我来说是，我17岁的时候，我记得非常清楚，
and I read On the Road by Jack Kerouac. And it sounds so cliche, but fuck, I was 17, I remember this so clearly, and I read On the Road by Jack Kerouac, and it sounds so cliche, but fuck, I was like, you can get out into the world? And that was actually spurred me to go, I can move to New York, and I moved when I was 20, and it was like, yeah, fucking Kerouac, that's what they did. Where did you grow up?
我读了杰克·凯鲁亚克的《在路上》。这听起来很老套，但该死，我17岁的时候，我记得非常清楚，我读了杰克·凯鲁亚克的《在路上》，这听起来很老套，但该死，我当时想，你可以走向世界？这实际上促使我决定，我可以搬到纽约去，我在20岁时搬了过去，就像，是的，该死的凯鲁亚克，他们就是这么做的。你在哪里长大的？
In Toronto, Canada, and you're like, that's what you do. If you wanna be out in the world, you gotta get out into the world, and that really spurred me on for the rest of my life. I love that. and you're like, that's what you do. If you want to be out in the world, you got to get out into the world. And that really spurred me on for the rest of my life. I love that. Daniel, what's going to happen with you for the rest of the day?
在加拿大多伦多，你会觉得，这就是你该做的。如果你想走向世界，你就必须走出去，这确实激励了我余下的人生。我喜欢这个。你会觉得，这就是你该做的。如果你想走向世界，你就必须走出去。这确实激励了我余下的人生。我喜欢这个。丹尼尔，你今天剩下的时间打算做什么？
And by the way, you live- We're going to talk about Queer. I want to hear a little bit about Queer. So Queer's out December 13th. You read the script, you think immediately. Do you think about the character? Are you thinking about that incredible director, Luca, Guadagnino?
顺便说一下，你住……我们要谈谈《酷儿》。我想听听关于《酷儿》的事。《酷儿》12月13日上映。你读了剧本，你立刻想到了什么？你在想这个角色吗？还是在想那位了不起的导演卢卡·瓜达尼诺？
Or what, what's going through your mind? Is it a quick yes? All of that, all of that. Yeah, all of that. That's like, I mean, I just, I wanted to work with Luca. I think he's, you know, he's just a really Incredible. Just exciting, kind of out there director
还是什么，你在想什么？是一个快速的“是的”吗？所有这些，所有这些。是的，所有这些。我的意思是，我只是，我想和卢卡合作。我觉得他，你知道，他是一个非常了不起的。只是一个令人兴奋的、那种前卫的导演，
who's just pushing it. But so it was a pretty quick yes, yes? Totally, yeah. Yeah. And the script, you know, was, I mean, yeah, I mean, getting offered a really complicated, interesting, funny, sad human being to play. I can't wait to see it.
他一直在突破界限。所以这是一个相当快的“是的”，对吧？完全正确，是的。是的。而且剧本，你知道，我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，能得到一个非常复杂、有趣、悲伤的人类角色来扮演。我迫不及待想看到它了。
I know, me too, me too. Congratulations on that. Yeah, thank you. All right, you're done, you've done great. Yeah, now you. Yeah. All right, you're done. You've done great. Yeah, now you can get your cold eggs there. I'm very sorry. That's all right, I'm just not going to eat
我知道，我也是，我也是。恭喜你。是的，谢谢。好了，你完成了，你做得很好。是的，现在轮到你了。是的。好了，你完成了。你做得很好。是的，现在你可以去吃你那冷掉的鸡蛋了。我很抱歉。没关系，我只是不打算吃
the potatoes in front of you. Sean will be here soon. But that's my personal, I've got a problem with that. I'll take them off your hands. I have to go to a dark cupboard and eat potatoes. Wait, Daniel, how, like, do you live in the UK? I do, I lived in New York, I lived in New York for nearly 20 years,
你面前的土豆。肖恩很快就会到。但这是我个人的问题，我对此有点意见。我会帮你解决它们的。我得去一个黑暗的橱柜里吃土豆。等等，丹尼尔，你，比如，你住在英国吗？是的，我住在纽约，我在纽约住了近20年，
no, 15 years, but, and moved back to London this summer. And do you love visiting LA, or are you like, I'm in, I'm out? I mean, it's kind of, you know, it's love-hate, it's all that thing, it's like, I really, I do love this, and I love California, and I love, I just, I went to the desert for a couple of days before I started this to get some kind of R&R.
不，15年，但是，今年夏天搬回了伦敦。你喜欢访问洛杉矶吗，还是说，我来了，我又走了？我的意思是，这有点，你知道，又爱又恨，就是那种感觉，就像，我真的，我确实喜欢这里，我喜欢加州，我喜欢，我只是，我在开始这个之前去了沙漠几天，为了得到某种休息和放松。
And it's like there's no place like this on Earth and then I want to leave really quickly. Now, last question, do you still follow Liverpool at all? Yes, yeah. You do? I do, yeah, religiously, yeah. Yeah, same. I don't get to many games, sadly, but now You do? I do, yeah, religiously, yeah. Same. I don't get to many games, sadly, but now I'm back in England.
就像地球上没有比这更好的地方了，然后我很快就想离开。现在，最后一个问题，你还关注利物浦队吗？是的，是的。你关注吗？我关注，是的，非常虔诚地，是的。是的，我也是。遗憾的是，我没能去看很多比赛，但现在……你关注吗？我关注，是的，非常虔诚地，是的。我也是。遗憾的是，我没能去看很多比赛，但现在我回到了英国。
I'm hoping to get to New York. Let's come in the New Year. I'm going to come over there. Let's go to a game. Let's make this pledge. I would really like that. Okay, great. Yeah, I really like that.
我希望能在新年去纽约。我要去那边。我们去看一场比赛吧。我们立下这个誓言吧。我真的很喜欢这样。好的，太棒了。是的，我真的很喜欢这样。
Daniel, thank you so much for doing this. Thank you. Thank you. I love you, Stan. Thank you. All right, buddy. Bye. Thank you.
丹尼尔，非常感谢你做这些。谢谢。谢谢。我爱你，斯坦。谢谢。好了，伙计。再见。谢谢。
I don't know how to stop this. There you go. Ah ha ha. Now there's a guy's guy. He's a woman's guy too. And he slammed the computer. You know, that's a great sign. Yeah, yeah. You love that, JB. I really do. He is, he's great.
我不知道怎么停止这个。好了。啊哈哈。那才是个真汉子。他也是个受女性欢迎的男人。而且他猛地关上了电脑。你知道，那是个很好的迹象。是的，是的。你喜欢那个，JB。我确实喜欢。他很棒，他真的很棒。
Like, you know, how do you talk to him without bringing up James Bond? I can't tell if he's sick of it or he's like. I think we did a good job of not peppering him with all the shit he's been asked, maybe. I don't know, I've never seen an interview with him. I mean, I always say this on this little podcast of ours, is like, when I meet people I've never met before like that,
就像，你知道，你怎么在不提起詹姆斯·邦德的情况下和他交谈？我看不出他是厌倦了还是……我觉得我们做得很好，没有用他被问过无数次的那些烂问题来轰炸他，也许吧。我不知道，我从来没看过他的采访。我的意思是，我总是在我们这个小播客上说，当我遇到像那样我从未见过的人时，
and I'm huge fans, of course I want to ask them all the fan questions, but I'm nervous. Yeah. I know. You know, like... How many films have you seen a billion times? I want to get down to your numbers now. Yeah, I mean, I've honestly, I've seen that so many times. I've seen all of them so many times.
而且我是他们的超级粉丝，我当然想问他们所有粉丝的问题，但我很紧张。是的。我知道。你知道，就像……你看过多少次电影看了十亿遍？我现在想了解一下你的数字。是的，我的意思是，老实说，我看过很多次了。我把它们都看了很多次。
But Skyfall is Scottie's favorite. And we've seen that many, many times. I want to see that, that's incredible. It's really good. Skyfall? You've never seen Skyfall? That's the one, right? Oh, it's so good. Wait, are you kidding, Jay?
但《007：大破天幕杀机》是斯科蒂的最爱。我们看过很多很多次了。我想看那个，那太不可思议了。它真的很棒。《天幕杀机》？你从来没看过《天幕杀机》？那是那部，对吧？哦，它太棒了。等等，你在开玩笑吗，杰伊？
It's so good. No, I'm not. Invite me over for Christ's sake. Wait, Jason, Skyfall is amazing. Yeah, it's amazing. I want to see it. And you love Javier Bardem. He takes his teeth out and is fucking crazy. Spoiler alert.
它太棒了。不，我没有。看在上帝的份上，邀请我过去吧。等等，杰森，《天幕杀机》太棒了。是的，它太棒了。我想看它。而且你喜欢哈维尔·巴登。他把牙齿拿出来，简直疯了。剧透警告。
Wait, what's your favorite line that he ever said? Oh, yeah. Oh, this, my ear. I hear it through my ear. Take your hand away from your ear. Take your hand away from your ear. Oh, what a line. Yeah.
等等，他说的最让你喜欢的台词是什么？哦，是的。哦，这个，我的耳朵。我通过我的耳朵听到它。把你的手从耳朵上拿开。把你的手从耳朵上拿开。哦，多么棒的台词。是的。
No, because it kicked up the whole thing. Is James Bond around? That was another one. Yeah, nearly lost a mark. Is James Bond around? That was another one. No, but- Go ahead, go ahead, Sean. Oh, Sean, hey Sean, I know you were gonna say, fuck me, dude, watching your face try to line up on by. Because he looks down at the computer,
不，因为它引发了整件事。詹姆斯·邦德在附近吗？那是另一句。是的，差点丢了分。詹姆斯·邦德在附近吗？那是另一句。不，但是……继续，继续，肖恩。哦，肖恩，嘿肖恩，我知道你想说什么，去你的，伙计，看着你的脸试图跟上节奏。因为他低头看着电脑，
because he kind of works on them, I think. Of course he does. No, no, I had one, I have one. Have we ever gotten a bunch of suggestions from our listeners of what we can do for our buys? I know, but do we have a portal for them to fill? A portal? Fill our portal?
因为我想他是在处理它们。他当然是。不，不，我有一个，我有一个。我们有没有从听众那里得到过一堆关于我们可以为我们的“买入”做些什么的建议？我知道，但我们有一个让他们填写的门户网站吗？一个门户网站？填我们的门户网站？
What do you mean? Or some sort of a site they can put all these recommendations so we can stop listening to Sean's shitty buys. But also, it's not the shitty buys. No, it's not. It's the way he goes. It's the way he goes, blah, blah, blah, blah, and he goes, yeah, so also I was thinking that,
你是什么意思？或者某种网站，他们可以把所有这些建议放进去，这样我们就可以停止听肖恩那些烂买入建议了。但同时，那也不是烂买入建议。不，不是。是他说话的方式。是他说话的方式，吧啦吧啦吧啦，然后他说，是的，所以我也在想那个，
and you're like, fuck, dude. Here it comes. What are you doing? No, I was gonna say, what does Stye, what does Jason Stye rhyme with? No, that's no good. Will, you got one? I don't have one.
然后你会说，该死，伙计。它来了。你在做什么？不，我想说的是，Stye，杰森·Stye押什么韵？不，那不好。威尔，你有一个吗？我没有。
No, that's, I'm no, I'm glad that it's. You should be guest- Will, you got one? I don't have one. That's mine. No, that's... No, I'm glad that it's... You should be guest-related. You know, it should be tied into the guest somehow. Well, I mean... Skyfall, its original title was... Vy-e-fall! Hahaha! Sounds like you got yourselves in a little bind.
不，那……不，我很高兴它是……你应该……威尔，你有一个吗？我没有。那是我的。不，那……不，我很高兴它是……你应该和嘉宾相关。你知道，它应该以某种方式与嘉宾联系起来。好吧，我的意思是……《天幕杀机》，它的原名是……Vy-e-fall！哈哈！听起来你们陷入了一点困境。
Ah! Robbie! SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess is 100% organic
啊！罗比！SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess是100%有机的
and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armgerf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并且由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆格夫手工制作。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。